ओके। सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव।
अ लेट मी सी इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। सो प्लीज लेट मी नो वंस गाइज़। इफ आई
एम ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल क्लियरली। एक बार
मुझे बता दीजिए सभी लोग।
अ ऑडियो वीडियो सही आ रही है? गुड इवनिंग।
गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी। गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू। नमस्ते।
ऑडियो वीडियो आप लोगों को सही आ रही है
क्या? बिल्कुल। जस्ट लेट मी नो गाइस।
ओके सभी को एक बार आ जाने देते हैं एंड एक
बार जल्दी से बता भी दीजिए
ऑल क्लियर क्लियर मुझे लग रहा है कि
नेटवर्क इशू है आई थिंक
ओके लेट मी चेक माय ऑन माय साइड
ओके लेट मी चेक माय
ओके आई थिंक सब कुछ सही है।
ओके ठीक है। अभी तो फिलहाल सही है। रेस्ट
देख लेते हैं। अगर आपको
डिफरेंट लगेगा तो आप मुझे बताइएगा। अगर
थोड़ा भी अगर अलग लगे नेटवर्क इशू हो या
नेटवर्क इशू फील हो तो प्लीज लेट मी नो इन
द चैट सेक्शन। ओके? सो सभी को एक बार जॉइन
करने देते हैं। एक बार सभी को आ जाने देते
हैं। देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग। आई होप आप
सभी बढ़िया होंगे। गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ
यू। नमस्ते। नमस्ते। गुड इवनिंग एंड
नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
ओके।
ओके। ठीक है। ओके। सो मेनी ऑफ़ यू हैव
ऑलरेडी जॉइ। चलिए। तो बिफोर वी स्टार्ट एज
आई से
एक चीज जो आपको सबसे ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है
जो आपको करनी होती है मैं आपको बता देता
हूं यहां पे आई थिंक
सबसे पहले आप डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube
चैनल ओपन कर लेंगे एंड यहां जब ओपन कर
लेंगे तो लाइव सेक्शन में आप जाएंगे एंड
लाइव सेक्शन में जाने के बाद यहां आपको
एसओसी की जो भी वीडियोस आपको मिलेंगी पहले
की जो भी वीडियोस होंगी किसी भी एक वीडियो
को आप ओपन कर लीजिएगा। एनी वीडियो यू कैन
ओपन लाइक मैंने ये 17 वाली जो वीडियो है
ओपन करी। इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइएगा।
यहां पे आपको दो लिंक्स मिलेंगे WhatsApp
के। एक ग्रुप का मिलेगा और एक WhatsApp
चैनल का मिलेगा। इन दोनों को ओपन कर
लीजिएगा। एक WhatsApp ग्रुप जो है यह
स्पेशली आपका एसओसी का ग्रुप है। दिस इज़
स्पेशली एसओसी ग्रुप। मैं यहां पे एक बार
आई थिंक कुछ तो नेटवर्क का इशू मुझे लग
रहा है।
डोंट नो व्हाट इज़ द इशू एक्चुअली हैपनिंग
हियर।
या आई थिंक अब सही है।
आई थिंक नाउ दिस इज़ परफेक्ट।
ओके। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। सो YouTube पे आप जो दोनों लिंक्स
ओपन करेंगे तो किसी भी एसओसी के प्रीवियस
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन से दोनों लिंक ओपन
कर लीजिएगा WhatsApp का। एक जो आपका लिंक
है दैट इज द एसओसी एनालिस्ट ग्रुप जो कि
आपको ज्वाइन कर लेना है क्योंकि इस पूरे
ट्रेनिंग की जितने भी रिसोर्सेज हैं
पीडीएफ हैं नोट्स हैं या अपकमिंग जो भी
सर्टिफिकेशन या किसी भी चीज की डिटेल होगी
वो सब इसी ग्रुप में आने वाली है तो इसको
जरूर जॉइ कीजिएगा सेकंड हमारा WhatsApp
चैनल है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी नाम से आप
WhatsApp चैनल पे जाके भी सर्च कर सकते
हैं डिफ्रॉनिक्स यू विल गेट दिस WhatsApp
चैनल यहां आपको ओवरऑल हमारी तरफ से जो भी
चीजें आती है हमारी तरफ से ओवरऑल जो भी
इंफॉर्मेशन या जो भी लॉन्च होती है, जो भी
चीजें फ्री या पेड या कोर्सर्सेस,
ट्रेनिंग्स कंपनी के बारे में सब कुछ सबसे
पहले आपको यहां मिलेगा। तो चैनल को फॉलो
कर लीजिएगा। यह दोनों काम बिल्कुल मस्ट
है। कर लीजिएगा। एंड इसके बाद आपको
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां Lindin
पे मैं मिल जाऊंगा। आप मुझसे कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं टेक्निकल नेविगेटर हैंडल पे। एंड
यहां पे आप मुझसे कनेक्ट हो के मुझसे
इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं, फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
आपकी एंड यहां पे डेफ़्रोनिक्स जब आप सर्च
करेंगे Lindin पे ही जाके व्हनेवर यू विल
सर्च फॉर डेफ़्रोनिक्स तो आपको डेफ़्रोनिक्स
हमारा जो कंपनी पेज है वो आपको मिल जाएगा।
अ मैं आपको यहां पे दिखा देता हूं।
लेट मी ओपन इट।
आज नेटवर्क इशू है थोड़ा सा। आई डोंट नो
व्हाई देयर इज़ नेटवर्क इशू बट थोड़ा सा
नेटवर्क इशू आज है ऐसा मुझे लग रहा है।
ओके तो ये Lindin पेज आपको मिल जाएगा यहां
पे।
यहां पे ये Lindin पेज मिल जाएगा। यहां पे
आप इस Lindin पेज को फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी को। इस पेज पे
आपको हमारे कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग, हमारी
स्टार्टअप के रिगार्डिंग जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन
है, जो भी अपडेट्स हैं, आपको मिलती रह
जाएंगी। हमारे न्यू प्रोडक्ट ल्च या
व्हाटएवर वी आर डूइंग वी यू विल बी
नोटिफाइड थ्रू दिस पर्टिकुलर पेज। यह
Instagram प्रोफाइल है। मेरी खुद की
पर्सनल प्रोफाइल है। यह हैंडल है ऊपर।
आपके एड्रेस बार में दिख रहा होगा। आप इस
पे मुझसे कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं। मुझे फॉलो
अप कर सकते हैं इफ यू वांट। एंड
नेट का इशू आ रहा है क्या? एक बार मुझे
बता दीजिए। नेटवर्क का इशू आ रहा है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके आई थिंक नेटवर्क का इशू थोड़ा बहुत तो
है। मैं एक बार स्पीड टेस्ट कर लेता हूं
Netflix सर्वर से कनेक्ट करके।
देयर इज सम इशू
सर आप आईआईटी से हो क्या? नहीं भाई मैं
आईआईटी से नहीं हूं। क्यों बताओ?
मैं आईआईटी से नहीं हूं। आईआईटी से होने
का मतलब क्या है? बताइए। चलिए मैं एक बार
यह वाला स्पीड टेस्ट कर लेता हूं। देख
लेता हूं कि व्हाट इज द इशू? Netflix
सर्वर तक तो सही से स्पीड नहीं पहुंच पा
रही है।
लेट्स चेक एट दिस लेवल। यस। सो नेटवर्क
स्पीड इज वेरी लेस।
नेटवर्क स्पीड जो है वह थोड़ी सी कम है
क्योंकि यहां पे 300 Mbps की स्पीड है बट
अभी सिर्फ 65 Mbps के आसपास का यह शो कर
रहा है। सो दिस इज नॉट गुड। यह सही नहीं
है। दिस इज़ बैड। ऐसा क्यों हो रहा है? लेट
मी सी। लेट मी चेक वंस।
ओके स्पीड इज
स्पीड इशू है थोड़ा सा
आई थिंक
ओके स्पीड इशू है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कोई बात नहीं
चलिए
ओके एक बार और वापस से चेक कर लेते हैं।
मैंने कुछ किया है यहां पर नेटवर्क का कुछ
हल्का सा मैंने किया है। वापस से मैं चेक
कर लेता हूं एक बार। लेट्स चेक वंस अगेन
कि ये 65 Mbps से ऊपर बढ़ रहा है या नहीं
हो रहा। सो एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं फिर
से।
तो इट्स कनेक्टिंग
हम अभी आई थिंक बेटर स्पीड आपको मिल जाएगी
मुझे ऐसा लग रहा है। ठीक है। अभी सही है।
नाउ एवरीथिंग इज फाइन राइट।
चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अभी सही आ रही है गाइस
अभी बिल्कुल सही है एक बार बता दो फटाफट
ओके लव फ्रॉम इंडिया ब्रदर ओके आई थिंक आई
थिंक नाउ इट्स गुड लेट्स चेक वि द Netflix
fst.com
इफ द स्पीड इज़ ऑप्टिमाइज्ड ऑ नॉट
आई होप दिस टाइम इट्स गुड।
चलिए इसको टेस्ट करने देते हैं। तब तक हम
यहां पर आ जाते हैं। सो दिस इज द
Instagram पेज जहां पे आप मुझसे कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं। ये मेरी प्रोफाइल है। पर्सनल
पेज है ये। यह हमारी कंपनी की पेज है।
डिफ़ॉन एकडमी। आप यहां पे आके कंपनी को
फॉलो अप कर सकते हैं। वेरियस टाइप ऑफ
इनेशन रील कंटेंट्स के लिए। यह हमारा एक्स
का पेज है। डिफ़ॉनस एकडमी हैंडल के साथ। आप
इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। ये हमारी वेबसाइट
है जहां पे आके आप हमारी वेबसाइट को
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। एकडमी पे जाके
हमारे कोर्सर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं। कोर्सर्सेस ऑफर्ड बाय डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंड यहां पे हमारा नंबर
है कांटेक्ट नंबर। आप इस पे हमसे कांटेक्ट
करके किसी भी तरह की आपकी कोई क्वेरी हो,
क्वेश्चन हो तो आप हमसे पूछ सकते हैं।
हमसे इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं। अपनी क्वेरीज
को पूछ सकते हैं। राइट?
ओके। ओके। चलिए। सो ऑल डन नाउ लेट्स
स्टार्ट विद द टुडेेस कंटेंट।
एंड यहां पर स्पीड का थोड़ा सा इशू अभी भी
लग रहा है मुझे। ऐसा फील हो रहा है।
आई थिंक यहां पे ज्यादा इशू है।
ओके। अ एक काम करते हैं। लेट मी कनेक्ट
विद द नेटवर्क
वंस अगेन विद माय ऑफ माय पीसी। एक बार मैं
वापस से आई थिंक अब जाकर बेटर नेटवर्क आ
जाएगा शायद। लेट्स सी
अब बेटर हो जाएगा। आई थिंक इट विल बी गुड।
नाउ लेट्स रीलोड इट।
ओके इट शुड बी गुड नाउ।
ओके। जस्ट बी वर्किंग नाउ
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] हां जी अब
बिल्कुल सही हो चुका है हमारा नेटवर्क नाउ
इट्स टोटली फाइन आई थिंक
हां जी अब टोटली इट्स टोटली फाइन नाउ
स्पीड इज़ आल्सो कमिंग गुड एंड लेट मी चेक
वंस कि आप लोगों को क्लियर आ रही है मुझे
एक बार बता दीजिए सभी लोग इफ एवरीथिंग इज़
फाइन गाइज़ नाउ एवरीथिंग इज़ फाइन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
प्लीज लेट मी नो एक बार लाइक ठोकते चले
जाओ हम स्टार्ट करते हैं।
या नाउ द स्पीड इज़ आल्सो कमिंग फाइन।
स्पीड इज़ आल्सो कमिंग एब्सोलुटली ग्रेट।
चलिए कुछ इशूज़ था वो इशू रिज़ॉल्व हो चुका
है। नाउ [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वी विल
बी स्टार्टिंग राइट। ओके। सो गाइज़ देखो,
अभी तक आपने जितने भी टॉपिक्स करे हैं,
व्हाटएवर टॉपिक्स यू हैव डन। मैं आपको एक
चीज़ बता देता हूं यहां पे फॉर योर काइंड
इनेशन।
हमने अभी तक एसओसी के बेसिक्स कर लिए हैं।
हमने एसओसी के लिए जो साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
मॉड्यूल था वो भी खत्म हो गया। वो भी
कंप्लीट हो चुका था। उसके कुछ टॉपिक बचे
थे वो आज कंप्लीट हो जाएंगे। तो ये भी
आपका कंप्लीट हो गया। नेटवर्किंग के जो भी
टॉपिक थे वो भी आपका कंप्लीट हो चुका है।
अब जो बच गया है ये सारे टॉपिक जो है आपके
कंप्लीटेड टॉपिक्स हैं।
ठीक है? अब जो आपको बच गया है लेफ्ट
टॉपिक्स
यह है ओएस रिलेटेड
ओएस रिलेटेड टॉपिक्स एंड द नेक्स्ट इज़
एसओसी एडवांस्ड जो एसओसी के एडवांस
टॉपिक्स हैं विद प्रैक्टिकल
वो आपके बच गए हैं जो होने बचे हैं जो कि
आपके दो मेजर टॉपिक्स बच गए। ये दोनों
वैसे तो छोटे दिख रहे हैं आपको टॉपिक्स बट
ये दोनों बहुत मेजर टॉपिक्स हैं। एंड
इनमें ये जब टॉपिक्स हम कंप्लीट कर लेंगे
तो आपका एसओसी एल1 जो ये ट्रेनिंग है वो
कंप्लीट हो जाएगा। एंड देन हम आगे नेक्स्ट
प्रोसीड करेंगे। इसके आगे की जो भी
प्रोसेससेस हैं जो जो चीजें हैं वो सब हम
कवर अप करेंगे। मित्र्रे वगैरह सब पे
क्लासेस होंगी भाई। टेंशन नहीं लेना आपको।
एसओसी एडवांस में जो Myra फ्रेमवर्क है या
एमआईटीआर फ्रेमवर्क जो भी आप बोलते हो तो
वो Myra [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
फ्रेमवर्क जो है वो सारा कुछ उसमें कवर
होने वाला है। अभी तो एडवांस बचा हुआ है
ना तो अभी अभी टेंशन नहीं लेना है। इतनी
जल्दी जल्दीबाजी नहीं रखनी है। हड़बड़ाना
नहीं है। बस फ्लो के साथ जाइए। ठीक है?
चलिए। सो टुडेज़ टॉपिक इज़ क्वाइट
इंटरेस्टिंग। आज का टॉपिक जैसे बाकी
टॉपिक्स भी होते हैं बहुत काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग होते हैं। वैसे ही आज का
टॉपिक भी है। काफी इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाला
है। काफी काफी इनफेटिव है। आपको ध्यान
रखना है। आज ये जो टॉपिक्स हैं ये आपके
साइबर सिक्योरिटी वाले टॉपिक्स से कुछ
टॉपिक रह गए थे। वो टॉपिक्स हम इसको कवर
अप करके जैसे ही कवर अप ये आज के टॉपिक हो
जाएगी। आज की क्लास हो जाएगी। आपका पूरा
साइबर सिक्योरिटी कंप्लीट हो जाएगा।
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी नेटवर्क नेटवर्किंग जो
टॉपिक्स थे वो सारे कंप्लीटेड हैं आपके।
अब नेक्स्ट जो क्लासेस होंगे उसमें ओएस
रिलेटेड टॉपिक्स चलेंगे जैसे Windows के
और लinक्स के टॉपिक्स। मेनली आपके Windows
और Linux के टॉपिक्स होंगे जो कि हम कवर
कर लेंगे। जैसे ही वो खत्म होगा हमारा
एसओसी एडवांस शुरू हो जाएगा जिसमें कि
आपका एडवांस बहुत डीप में अलर्टिंग का हो
गया, ट्रैगिंग हो गया। आपका लॉगिंग हो गई।
उसके बाद उसको समझना कैसे एस्केलेट करना
है। फिर एसआईएम्स टूल्स हो गए। जो भी
टेक्नोलॉजीज़ हैं उस पे एमआईटीआरई हो गया।
देयर आर अ लॉट ऑफ़ थिंग्स जिस पे कि हम काम
करने वाले हैं जो कि हम देखेंगे एडवांस
में एंड उसके साथ-साथ आपके लैब्स,
प्रैक्टिकल्स, डेमोंस्ट्रेशनंस सब साथ में
होंगे एंड देन आपका ये ट्रेनिंग खत्म
होगा। तो चलिए आज का सेशन हम अ स्टार्ट
करते हैं। ठीक है?
ओके। सो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] टुडे वी
आर गोइंग टू स्टार्ट विद द डीएनएस
फुटप्रिंटिंग टॉपिक। अब आपके दिमाग में यह
भी आ सकता है कि सर डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग
से पहले डीएनएस नहीं कर सकते हैं क्या? तो
डीएनएस आप सब मुझे बताइए द एवरीवन प्लीज
लेट मी नो कि इफ वी हैव कवर्ड डीएनएस ऑ
नॉट टिल नाउ। अभी मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए
कि क्या हमने अभी तक डीएनएस कवर करा है या
नहीं करा है। सो लेट मी नो। जल्दी बता
दीजिए। फटाफट बताइए।
प्लीज लेट मी नो फास्ट। डीएनएस आपका कवर
हुआ है कि नहीं?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। कवर है। काफी लोग बोल रहे हैं कवर
है। अगर स्टिल आप वैसे हैं जिनको आईडिया
नहीं है कि डीएनएस हमने कवर करा है कि
नहीं करा है। मैं आपको पहले ही बता देता
हूं कि डीएनएस
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] क्या होती
है? कैसे काम करती है? इसको हमने ऑलरेडी
कवर कर लिया है। अगर आपको नहीं पता तो
डिफ्रॉनिक्स चैनल पे आप चले जाइएगा। लाइव
सेक्शन में चले जाइएगा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] और एसओसी की
ही जो क्लासेस हुई थी उसमें जो यह क्लास
है क्लास नंबर 14 जिसमें हमने डीएनएस
स्पोर्ट्स एंड प्रोटोकॉल्स इन सबको बहुत
डिटेल में कवर करा था इसको देख लीजिएगा
आपको क्लियर हो जाएगा कि एग्जैक्टली
डीएनएस क्या होता है कैसे काम करती है ये
सब कुछ आपको पता चल जाएगा तो आज हम
स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग
से डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग को समझेंगे डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग को समझेंगे एंड इन दोनों को
देखेंगे क्या होता है एंड देन साथ में एक
और टॉपिक है हम उसको भी कवर करेंगे तो
पहले हम बात करते हैं डीएनएस फुटप्रिंट
प्रिंटिंग डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग का मतलब है
डीएनएस का यूज़ करके डिटेल्स फाइंड करना।
एज़ सिंपल एज़ दैट डीएनएस का यूज़ करके जितनी
डिटेल हम निकाल सकते हैं निकालना या अटैकर
जितनी डिटेल निकाल सकता है उसको निकालना।
ठीक है? तो डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग का मतलब
होता है डीएनएस के थ्रू कलेक्टिंग इनेशन
अबाउट अ टारगेट यूजिंग डीएनएस। अगर कोई
अटैकर है तो उसको टारगेट के अगेंस्ट कोई
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन निकालनी है। टारगेट के अ
टारगेट के सेम बहुत सारी इनेशन गैदर करनी
है तो वो ऐसे इंफॉर्मेशनेशंस कलेक्ट करने
का एक तरीका निकालता है जिसको हम डीएनएस
फुटप्रिंटिंग बोलते हैं। यानी कि डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड के थ्रू जो है वो डिटेल्स को
फाइंड करना। अब ये
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जो डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड्स है ये बेसिकली होते कहां है?
बहुत लोगों के मन में होगा। देखो डीएनएस
जो रिकॉर्ड्स होते हैं जब आप कहीं जो भी
आप होस्टिंग प्रोवाइडर से जब आप डोमेन
वगैरह खरीदते हो तो वहां पे डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड्स भी आप कॉन्फ़िगर कर सकते हैं या
कोई भी कोई भी लाइक किसी भी तरह का आप
सर्विस प्रोवाइडर यूज़ करते हो चाहे आप
ब्लू होस्ट यूज़ करो होस्टिंगर यूज़ करो
चाहे GDAD यूज़ करो एनी काइंड ऑफ़ सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर जिससे कि आप अपनी वेबसाइट्स
वगैरह को या वेब एप्लीकेशन को होस्ट करते
हो वहां पे आप अपना डीएनएस कॉन्फ़िगर कर
सकते हो। इसके अलावा आप क्लाउड फ्लेयर
जैसी एप्लीकेशनेशंस जो होती हैं। ठीक है?
क्लाउड फ्लेयर क्लाउड फ्लेयर जो कि एक
सीडीएन होता है। बनी जो कि एक सीडीएन है
कंटेंट डिलीवरी नेटवर्क। ऐसे सर्विज के
ऊपर भी आप डीएनएस को होस्ट कर सकते हो। यू
कैन कॉन्फ़िगर द डीएनएस। तो वहां पे भी आप
डीएनएस। अब डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड होता है एक।
ठीक है? अब वो किस तरह का रिकॉर्ड होता
है, मैं आपको यहां पे दिखाता हूं।
मैं क्लाउड फेयर के डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स को
आपको शो करने की कोशिश करता हूं। यहां पर
इमेज पर चलते हैं।
लेट्स सी। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? तो क्लाउड फेयर के अंदर में
डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स कुछ इस तरीके से आपको
दिखते हैं। जैसे कि मैं यहां पे
हम कोई एक बड़ी सी एंट्री देखते हैं।
जिसमें मल्टीपल डीएनएस एंट्रीज हो।
हम यह रही।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कुछ इस तरह की डीएनएस एंट्रीज होती हैं
क्लाउड फेयर के अंदर में। ठीक है? क्लाउड
फेयर में जब आप लॉग इन करते हैं तो वहां
पर जाने पे एक डीएनएस का ऑप्शन आता है।
क्लाउड फ्लेयर एक फ्री सर्विस है जो कि
कंटेंट डिलीवरी नेटवर्क का एक काम एक
सर्विस प्रोवाइड करती है। जहां पे कंटेंट
डिलीवरी नेटवर्क का मतलब क्या होता है?
मुझे बता दीजिए। एनीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो इन
द चैट सेक्शन। जितने भी लोग यहां प्रेजेंट
हैं कि कंटेंट डिलीवरी नेटवर्क सीडीएन का
काम एग्जैक्टली क्या होता है? किसी को पता
है क्या यहां पर कोई बता सकता है टाइप
करके
बता दीजिए एक बार फटाफट बताइए प्लीज डोंट
स्पैम स्पैम आप अगर करते हैं तो आपका टाइम
आउट आपको कर दिया जाएगा
सर हम एसओसी स्किल से क्रूज शिप की आईटी
फील्ड में इंटरव्यू दे सकते हैं अगर एसओसी
प्रोफाइल है तो बिल्कुल दे सकते हैं एसओसी
प्रोफाइल है डेफिनेटली यू कैन गो वो वो
क्रूज शिप पे हो चाहे वो चांद पे हो एसओसी
की प्रोफाइल होनी चाहिए।
देखो कंटेंट डिलीवरी नेटवर्क जो होता है
वो एक ऐसी सर्विस प्रोवाइडर होती है जो कि
आपके सर्वर के आपका जो सर्वर है उसके
बिहाफ में कंटेंट्स को डिलीवर करता है
यूज़र्स को। जैसे कि अब मान लो कि मेरी
वेबसाइट है dfonic.com
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? यह dfin.com वेबसाइट है। अब इस
वेबसाइट पर बहुत सारे इमेज होंगे। बहुत
सारे डाटा होंगे। html कंटेंट होगा,
सीएसएस कंटेंट होगा। बहुत सारी इमेजज़
होंगी, फाइल्स होंगी। अब ये सारे इमेजज़
फाइल्स जब यूज़र्स मेरे वेबसाइट पे विजिट
करते हैं या किसी भी वेबसाइट को विजिट
करते हैं हमारी किसी भी पोर्टल को, तो ये
जो इमेजज़ आते हैं, जो फाइल्स आती हैं, ये
मेरे अगर सर्वर से डायरेक्ट आएंगी।
डायरेक्ट मेरे सर्वर से। तो क्या होगा?
सर्वर पे हमेशा लोड पड़ता है। हमेशा सर्वर
के पास रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी। सर्वर उसको
रिसोंड करेगा। सर्वर काफी बिजी रहता है।
बट अगर यही चीज़ एक सीडीएन करने लगता लगता
है। जैसे कि एक क्लाउड फेयर सीडीएन है
कंटेंट डिलीवरी नेटवर्क। तो क्या होता है
कि एक सर्वर।
सो व्हाट हैपेंस?
अगर सीडीएन काम कर रहा है उस केस में।
उस केस में क्या होता है
कि जो एक ब्राउज़र है यानी कि जो बेसिकली
आपका यूज़र्स के लिए और एक जो सर्वर है मान
लो ये dfonic.com है।
मान लो यह है
dfonic.com
और यह जो है यूज़र्स हैं जो इसको एक्सेस
करना चाहते हैं। तो पहले जब यूज़र्स एक्सेस
कर रहे थे तो सर्वर को रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहे
थे एंड सर्वर इनको रिस्पॉन्ड कर रहा था।
बट अब जो है अगर बीच में यहां पे सीडीए एक
मैं यूज़ करने लगूं। सीडीए
यहां पे मैं मान के चलता हूं ये सीडीएन
किसका है? अ क्लाउड फ्लेयर का है।
क्लाउड फ्लेयर का ये सीडीएन है। लेट्स
सपोज़
राइट? अगर मैं ये क्लाउड फ्लेयर का सीडीएन
यूज़ करने लगूं तो व्हाट विल हैपन? कि जो
भी रिक्वेस्ट है वो अब जो भी रिक्वेस्ट
जाएगी उसको फुलफिल कौन करेगा? यह हमारा
सीडीएन करेगा। यानी हमारे सीडीएन का एक
कैश मेमोरी होगा। एक कैश मेमोरी होगा।
एंड जब रिक्वेस्ट आएगी तो यह सीडीए ही
इसको फुलफिल कर देगा। सर्वर पर लोड नहीं
पड़ेगा। बट एक टाइम पे एक टाइम इंटरवल पे
एक टाइम गैप के बाद सीडीए क्या करेगा?
अपनी तरफ से सर्वर से वो फाइल्स जो है वो
वापस से फ्रेश फैच करेगा। कुछ टाइम के
बाद। अब जैसे ये हो सकता है ना कि मेरी
वेबसाइट पे कोई मैंने चेंज किया हो, इमेजज़
चेंज की है, कुछ किया है। तो इसका एक फाइल
सर्विंग का एक लिमिटेशन एक टाइम गैप होता
है कि जैसे चलो कि क्या करेगा कि मैं दो
दिनों तक ना सर्वर की फाइल्स को सर्व करता
रहूंगा और तीसरे दिन क्या करूंगा? वापस से
ये क्लाउड फेयर का काम होगा। वापस से
सर्वर के पास जाऊंगा। बोलूंगा कि भाई आपके
पास कोई फ्रेश न्यू अपडेटेड फाइल्स हैं या
यू आपके जो आपके जो ओनर है उन्होंने कुछ
चेंज किया है इमेजज़ के अंदर में या मेटा
या जो डेटा है उनके अंदर में या कोई फाइल
के अंदर में तो अगर कुछ नया चेंजेस हुए
हैं नए कुछ इमेजज़ आए हैं तो मुझे वापस से
वो वो चीजें जो चेंज है चीजें वापस से
मुझे कर दो। तो सर्वर क्या करेगा? वापस से
उसको फ्रेश फाइल्स दे देगा। अब क्लाउड
फेयर ने अपने कैश में वापस से वो फाइल्स
को सेव कर ली। अब वापस से जब कोई क्लाइंट
मेरे वेबसाइट के थ्रू फच करना चाहेगा उन
फाइल्स को तो डायरेक्ट क्लाउड फेयर ही
उनको डिलीवर करेगा। सर्वर के पास सारी
रिक्वेस्ट जाने की जरूरत नहीं है। तो इससे
होगा क्या कि सर्वर के ऊपर बहुत ज्यादा
लोड नहीं पड़ेगा। सर्वर थोड़ा सा मेरा
रिलैक्स फील करेगा एंड उसको मजा आएगा।
थोड़ा फास्ट रहेगा। ठीक है? ये काम होता
है बेसिकली आपके सीडीएंस का कंटेंट
डिलीवरी नेटवर्क का। तो इसके लिए जैसे मैं
क्लाउड फ्लेयर अगर यूज़ करूंगा तो मुझे
क्लाउड फ्लेयर के अंदर अपनी डीएनएस की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करनी पड़ेगी। पहले क्या था?
पहले मेरी डीएनएस की कॉन्फ़िगरेशन मेरी
होस्टिंग प्रोवाइडर जहां थी वहीं पे थी।
मान लो जैसे मैं अगर होस्टिंगर यूज़ कर रहा
हूं तो मेरी पहले जो डीएनएस की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन थी वो मेरी होस्टिंगर के अंदर
मैं करके रखता था। बट जैसे ही मैं क्लाउड
फ्लेयर को यूज़ कर रहा हूं कंटेंट डिलीवरी
के लिए। सो नाउ आई एम यूजिंग द क्लाउड
फ्लेयर डीएनएस ज़ोन एडिटर या क्लाउड फ्लेयर
का डीएनएस जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन ज़ोन है, मैं
उसको यूज़ कर रहा हूं। और वहां पे मैं अपनी
जो भी डोमेन की जो भी सीडीएंस जो भी मैं
डोमेन की डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स हैं, जो भी
डीएनएस एंट्रीज हैं, मैं सब अपने क्लाउड
फेयर में कर रहा हूं। तो क्लाउड फेयर हो
या कोई भी डोमेन की आपकी सीडीए
डोमेन की आपकी डीएनएस
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] रिकॉर्ड्स
डालने की हो सब एक ही तरह के होते हैं।
रिकॉर्ड्स एक ही होते हैं। रिकॉर्ड्स में
कोई चेंज नहीं होता। क्लाउड फेयर में
डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड डालो तो या फिर आप
डायरेक्ट होस्टिंग वाले आपके प्रोवाइडर के
पास डालो तो दोनों लगभग सेम ही होते हैं।
तो अब ये डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स किस तरीके के
होते हैं? जैसे देखो अब यहां पे है यहां
लिखा हुआ है ये चीज। आप इसको ध्यान से
पढ़िएगा। यहां लिखा हुआ है क्या लिखा हुआ
है? टू यूज़ क्लाउड फ्लेयर इंश्योर योर
ऑथरेटिव डीएनएस सर्वर्स और नेम सर्वर्स
हैव बीन चेंज्ड। दीज़ आर योर असाइन क्लाउड
फ्लेयर नेम सर्वर्स। अब यहां पे क्लाउड
फ्लेयर के नेम सर्वर्स आपको यहां पे देखने
को मिलेंगे। अब ये जो नेम सर्वर्स हैं
इसको आपके जो डोमेन आपका जो आपने जहां से
बेसिकली जो डोमेन लिया है जिस डोमेन को आप
यहां पे बेसिकली हो डोमेन को आप लेके
होस्ट कर रहे हो वहां के डीएनएस एडिटर में
जाके आपको ये वाली जो जो आपकी बेसिकली ये
वाली जो नेम सर्वर है इसको यूज़ करनी पड़ेगी
एंड देन ओनली यू कैन यूज़ द सीडीए क्लाउड
फ्लेयर सीडीएन एज योर कंटेंट डिलीवरी
नेटवर्क एंड देन आप क्लाउड फेयर के सीडीए
के सर्विस को भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं। डीएनएस
सर्विस को भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं। एंड इसके
डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स को जो है वो मॉडिफाई
करके डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स में आप अपने
रिकॉर्ड्स डाल सकते हैं। अब मुझे एक बात
बताइए ये बातें जो मैं बोल रहा हूं ये
क्या आपको समझ में आ रहा है? आर यू
अंडरस्टैंडिंग दिस? मुझे एक बार बताइए। आर
यू गेटिंग दिस?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
प्लीज लेट मी नो। आर यू गेटिंग दिस गाइज़?
एवरीवन गेटिंग दिस?
सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए एक बार सो दैट आई गेट
टू नो कि मैक्सिमम लोग को पता चल रहा है।
देखिए लेट आए हैं तब तो मैं रिपीट नहीं
करूंगा क्योंकि लेट अगर आए हैं तो आप
दोबारा रिकॉर्डिंग देख सकते हैं। बट अगर
नहीं समझ में आया तो थोड़ी मैं आपको चीजें
बता सकता हूं। लाइक देखो मैंने आपको वही
सेम चीज बताई है कि डीएनएस
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एंट्री क्या होती है? आपके डोमेन नेम
सिस्टम डीएनएस होता है। तो आपका जो डोमेन
प्रोवाइडर होता है जहां से आपने डोमेन
परचेस किया है। राइट?
एंड जहां से आपने होस्टिंग ली है वहां पर
आपको डीएनएस की कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करनी होती है।
बेसिकली डीएनएस का काम क्या होता है? एक
डोमेन को IP पे मैप करना। राइट? एक डोमेन
को IP पे मैप करना। अब जैसे आपने डोमेन
कहीं से लिया है। मान लो आपने होस्टिंगर
से लिया लिया डोमेन। अब जैसे मान लो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आपने
होस्टिंगर से डोमेन ले लिया है। एंड
होस्टिंगर से ही आपने क्या लिया है?
होस्टिंग ले ली है। ठीक है? [हंसी] अब
यहां पे डोमेन अगर है abc.com एंड
होस्टिंग की एक आईपी है 170 डॉट
ये एक रैंडम आईपी है। जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस।
अ जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस।
जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस।
जस्ट अ सेकंड। एक काम है मैं कर लेता हूं
फटाफट
हम हम
ओके
और
ओके चलिए। सो अब आपका जो डोमेन है बेसिकली
क्या होना चाहिए? व्हाट इट शुड बी लाइक कि
आपकी जो होस्टिंग है मान लो आपने होस्टिंग
ली है हुई है। ठीक है? एवरीवन इज़ नाउ
गेटिंग
ऑडियो वीडियो सही है। हां। अब आपके जो
डोमेन है वो पॉइंट करना चाहिए इस होस्टिंग
वाले पे। जो यह होस्टिंग है आपका इस पे
पॉइंट होना चाहिए। एज सिंपल एज दैट। इसका
मतलब है abc.com.com
शुड बी
पॉइंटिंग टू दिस पर्टिकुलर आईपी।
क्यों? क्योंकि हमारी इसी होस्टिंग जो
हमने सर्विस प्रोवाइड खरीदी है, बाय की
है। इसी होस्टिंग पे हमारा वेबसाइट चल रहा
है पूरा। वेबसाइट फाइल्स पड़ी हुई हैं।
वेबसाइट की जितनी भी फाइल्स हैं वो पड़ी
हुई हैं। दिस पर दिस ओनली आईपी पे। अब
यहां पे क्या होता है? देखो मैं आपको एक
चीज़ बताता हूं। अब इस वेबसाइट फाइल्स सारी
तो हमारी इस आईपी पे पड़ी है। होस्टिंग
प्रोवाइडर के पास पड़ी हुई है। यहां पे
हमारा ABC.com क्या है? बस एक डोमेन है।
कुछ भी नहीं है। डोमेन आप बाय कर भी लोगे
उसको ओपन करोगे तो क्या ओपन होगा? कुछ भी
नहीं ओपन होगा। अब मान लो कि मैं यहां पे
वेबसाइट हमारी ओपन करते हैं। टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर।
ठीक है? ये हमारी
वेबसाइट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ओपन
करते हैं। टेक्निकल नेविगेटर। ये भी हमारी
वेबसाइट है। अब मैंने इसको ओपन कर लिया।
अब इस वेबसाइट को हमने टेक्निकल nविator.
डोमेन एक बाय करी। बट इसको ओपन करने पे
हमारे पास इतने सारे आर्टिकल्स, इतने सारे
इमेजेस, पेजेस खुल रहे हैं। ये कहां से आ
रहे हैं? ये इसलिए आ रहे हैं क्योंकि हमने
इस वेबसाइट को कहीं होस्ट करके रखा है।
जिसकी आईपी ये होगी और यहीं पे सारी
वेबसाइट्स की फाइल्स पड़ी है। तो अब इस
डोमेन को इस आईपी पे मैप तो करना पड़ेगा
ना भाई। तभी तो इस डोमेन को ओपन करेंगे तो
बिहाइंड द सीन इस आईपी पे जो फाइल्स रखी
हुई है, होस्टेड हैं, वो सारी हमें मिल
जाएंगी। हमें देखने को मिलेंगी। तो
बेसिकली हमारे पास ये सारे पेजेस आएंगे।
तो ये जो पर्टिकुलर सारी फाइल्स अभी सर्व
की जा रही है वो हमारी होस्टिंगर सर्व कर
रहा है। क्योंकि हमने यहीं से होस्टिंग ली
है। बट जैसे ही हम अब यहां पे सीडीएन यूज़
करने वाले हैं जो कि हम मान लो
क्लाउड फ्लेयर यूज़ करेंगे एज अ सीडीएन।
नाउ जैसे ही हम सीडीएन यूज़ करेंगे क्लाउड
फ्लेयर। तो अब क्लाउड फ्लेयर क्या बोलेगा
कि भैया ठीक है सब चंगा है कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है चलेगा लेकिन अब क्या करना है ना
कि आप अगर मुझे यूज़ करना चाहते हो तो पहले
जब आपने ABC.com को यहां पे इस पे पॉइंट
किया था तो होस्टिंगर का अपना एक नेम
सर्वर होता है। होस्टिंगर का
अपना एक नेम सर्वर होता है। जैसे कि सर्वर
मान लो ns1.स्टिंग.com
ऐसे होगा। फिर एक और होगा मान लो अह ns2
डॉट होस्ट name server 1 hoinger.com
होस्टिंग
ड.com ऐसे होगा। तो पहले क्या होगा? ये
दोनों नेम सर्वर्स जो हैं ये इस डोमेन के
साथ कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड होंगे। इस डोमेन के अंदर
कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड होंगे। तो इसका मतलब है कि ये
डोमेन जो है होस्टिंगर के नेम सर्वर को
यूज़ कर रहा है और होस्टिंगर की ही होस्टेड
फाइल्स जो है डायरेक्ट होस्टिंगर से ही ले
रहा है ये हमारा डोमेन बस इसका मतलब ये
हुआ बट अब जैसे ही आप क्लाउड फेगीडी यूज़
करोगे क्लाउड फ्लेयर बोलेगा कि भैया ऐसे
तो नहीं काम चलेगा अब मेल भी एक नेम सर्वर
है जिसका नाम मैंने रखा है लिया डॉट
क्लाउड फ्लेयर डॉट
कुछ भी कुछ भी लाइक एनS रख दो ns1 कुछ भी
रख दो
ओगा डॉट
क्लाउड फ्लेयर.ns2 रख दो। व्हाटएवर नाम?
यह नाम कुछ भी हो सकता है। तो नाम को लेके
ज्यादा सीरियस और ज्यादा इमोशनल मत हो
जाना। ये नाम कुछ भी हो सकता है। व्हाटएवर
दे कैन प्रोवाइड। जैसे आपको यहां पे मैंने
इमेजज़ के अंदर दिखाया यहां पे ये नाम ns.
Fl gns fl ns.flare.com
यहां पे या लसी या कुछ भी करते हो। तो
यहां पे डॉट ही कर देते हैं। चलो ताकि
कंफ्यूज़ ना हो। चलो डॉट यहां पे कर दिया।
तो यहां पे इस तरीके से कुछ भी नाम हो। अब
ये एक सीडीए हमारा क्लाउड फेब बोलेगा कि
भैया जो पहले तुमने डो एबीसी डोमेन के लिए
हमारा ये वाला कॉन्फ़िगर किया था तुमने
अपने होस्टिंगर का। तो अब क्या करो कि इस
एबीसी के लिए तुम इसको कॉन्फ़िगर करो इस
दोनों नेम सर्वर को। तो अब इसके जगह पे
यहां पे
हमारे इसके जगह पे
ये ये भैया आ जाएंगे।
टिक मार्क का कुछ होता है क्या?
टिक मार्क का कुछ होता है? नहीं।
यह आ जाएंगे। एंड हमारे इसके जगह पे
यह जो चीज है इसके जगह पे दूसरा वाला जो
है हमारा सेकंड वाला जो क्लाउड फेयर का जो
हमारा नेम सर्वर था वह आ जाएगा।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो अब हमारे एबीसी डोमेन के लिए हमारा नया
नेम सर्वर जो है वह पहला यह वाला है lea
cloudflare.com मान लो दूसरा ओcloudfl.com
अब होस्टिंगर वाली नेम सर्वर्स को हमने
डोमेन के कॉन्फ़िगरेशन से हटा दिया है।
इसका मतलब ये है कि अब जो भी
रिक्वेस्ट्संगी जो भी चीजें होंगी देखो
फाइल्स जो आपकी वेबसाइट्स की है वो अभी भी
होस्टिंगर के ही होस्टेड जगह पे है।
क्योंकि आपने होस्टिंग होस्टिंगर से ली
है। होस्टिंग आप होस्टिंगर से ले सकते हो।
लेकिन आप पूरी डीएनएस जो मेंटेन करना है
यानी कि आपकी जो रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी वो
डायरेक्ट होस्टिंगर को ना जाके पहले
क्लाउड फ्लेयर को जाएगी। क्लाउड फ्लेयर जो
है फिर जाके होस्टिंगर से कांटेक्ट करके
एंड होस्टिंगर से आपको फाइल सर्व करके
देगा। यानी डायरेक्ट रिक्वेस्ट आपका मतलब
डायरेक्ट होस्टिंगर पे ना जाके क्लाउड
फेयर के थ्रू होके जाएगी। इसलिए क्लाउड
फेयर के नेम सर्वर को हमने होस्टिंगर के
डोमेन के लिए कॉन्फ़िगर कर दिया है। अब
क्लाउड फेयर के अंदर हम सारी डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड को मेंटेन करेंगे। पहले जब नहीं
किया था तो हम होस्टिंगर के अंदर ही सारी
डीएनएस जो रिकॉर्ड्स थे उनको मेंटेन करके
रख रहे थे। जितने भी डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स थे
जो भी चीजें हम कफ़िगर करते थे वो सारी हम
क्लाउड फ्लेयर के अंदर पहले नहीं करते थे।
पहले हम होस्टिंगर के अंदर करते थे। बट अब
इसके बाद अब हम सारी चीजें क्लाउड फ्लेयर
के अंदर कॉन्फ़िगर करेंगे। एवरीथिंग विल बी
कॉन्फ़िगर इन क्लाउड फ्लेयर। एंड क्लाउड
फ्लेयर में अब डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स डीएनएस
एंट्रीज़ होती हैं। जैसे कि यहां पे मैंने
इमेज में दिखाया था आप लोगों को। ये इमेज
में डीएनएस एंट्री है। इसी तरीके से आपके
डोमेन के पास भी एंट्री होती है। सारे
टाइप ए रिकॉर्ड बी टाइप सी नेम रिकॉर्ड,
टीx रिकॉर्ड, एमएक्स रिकॉर्ड और इसी तरीके
से होस्टिंगर में भी हो सॉरी क्लाउड फेयर
में भी होती है। तो बट क्योंकि हमने
डीएनएस अब क्लाउड फेयर का यूज़ किया है। तो
अब क्लाउड फेयर के अंदर डीएनएस की सारी
रिकॉर्ड्स एंट्री होगी। अब किस तरीके
रिकॉर्ड एंट्री होगी? क्या होगी? वो अभी
हम यहां पे देखेंगे। ठीक है? इतना समझ में
आ गया? पहले मुझे बता दीजिए। एवरीवन प्लीज
लेट मी नो इफ दिस इज़ अंडरस्टुड।
एक बार बता दीजिए फटाफट
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सभी लोग रिप्लाई कीजिए प्लीज।
सभी लोग तभी आई विल कंटिन्यू क्योंकि सबके
रिस्पांस नहीं आते।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ओके ठीक है।
अब जब डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड की बात करते हैं तो
डीएनएस के अंदर रिकॉर्ड के अंदर में यहां
पे कुछ इस तरीके के रिकॉर्ड्स होते हैं।
जैसे ए रिकॉर्ड, सी नेम रिकॉर्ड, एमएक्स
रिकॉर्ड, टीxटी रिकॉर्ड ये सारे रिकॉर्ड्स
होते हैं। ए रिकॉर्ड में आपका आईपी वर्जन
4 के लिए रिकॉर्ड होता है। जहां पे डोमेन
आपके आईपी पे मैप होता है। एमएक्स रिकॉर्ड
मेल सर्वर जहां से आप डोमेन मेलिंग सर्विस
जो होती है उसको यूज़ करते हैं। देन आपका
टीएक्सटी रिकॉर्ड होता है जिसमें कि
वेरियस अदर टेक्स्ट रिकॉर्ड्स होते हैं जो
कि आप यहां पे एंटर करते हैं। तो ये जो
सारी रिकॉर्ड्स और जो भी चीजें हैं ये
ऑलरेडी जो है मैंने आपको डीएनएस वाली जो
हमारी क्लास हुई थी जैसा कि मैंने आपको
बताया था उसमें ऑलरेडी बता चुका हूं मैं
ऑलरेडी आपको बता दी गई है कि हां कहां पे
ये क्या-क्या रिकॉर्ड्स होती हैं क्या काम
करती है तो वो क्लासेस आप देख सकते हैं
उसके लिए आज फिलहाल अभी के लिए हम किस चीज
पे फोकस करने वाले हैं वो है हमारा डीएनएस
फुटप्रिंटिंग पे ठीक है चलिए
लेट्स लोड इट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लेट्स स्टार्ट।
तो डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग कलेक्टिंग इनफेशन
अबाउट अ टारगेट यूजिंग डीएनएस। डीएनएस का
यूज़ करके अगर जो भी हम रिकॉर्ड या अह जो
भी हम अटैकर्स जो होते हैं डीएनएस का जब
यूज़ करके अह जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन निकालते हैं
उसको हम डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग कहा जाता है।
उसको हम डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग कहते हैं।
नहीं रिपीट अब नहीं कर सकते हैं क्योंकि
ऑलरेडी रिपीट कर दिया गया है। तो रिपीट
नहीं हो सकती है। अगर आपको वापस से देखना
है तो आई वुड रिक्वेस्ट यू टू प्लीज गो
थ्रू द अ रिकॉर्डिंग वंस। ठीक है? आप
रिकॉर्डिंग एक बार देख लीजिएगा। आपको
क्लियर आ जाएगा। क्लियर समझ में आ जाएगा।
ओके।
ओके। सो डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग इज़ कलेक्टिंग
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
कलेक्टिंग इनेशन अबाउट अ टारगेट
यूजिंग द डीएनएस। डीएनएस का यूज़ करके
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन कलेक्ट करना। ठीक है? इसका
इसका मतलब सिंपल होता है कि इंफॉर्मेशन को
गैदर करना या इंटेलिजेंस के थ्रू
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करना।
ठीक है? अब अटैकर का गोल क्या होता है?
अटैकर का गोल होता है कलेक्ट मैक्सिमम
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन विदाउट गेटिंग डिटेक्टेड।
ये अटैकर का गोल होता है कि मैक्सिमम से
मैक्सिमम इनेशन को हम अह यहां से निकाल
सके बिना डिटेक्ट हुए हुए। तो क्योंकि
डिटेक्ट हो जाएंगे तो फिर क्या ही मतलब है
अटैक का। तो विदाउट डिटेक्शन दे विल ट्राई
कि अ हम इंफॉर्मेशन निकालें डीएनएस के
थ्रू। ठीक है? अब अटैकर्स क्या फाइंड करने
की कोशिश करते हैं? सबसे पहले वो सब
डोमेनस सबडोमेन इनमरेशन करने की कोशिश
करेंगे। सो देयर आर अ चांसेस ऑफ़ सबडोमेन
इनमरेशन। देन इंटरनल सर्विसेस को डिस्कस
अह निकालने की कोशिश करेंगे। सबडोमेन तो
इनमरेट करेंगे ही। साथ में इंटरनल सर्विज
या इंटरनल सब डोमेनस जो कि जनरली किसी को
नहीं मिलने चाहिए वह निकालने की कोशिश
करेंगे। मेल सर्वर्स के रिकॉर्ड फाइंड
करने की कोशिश करेंगे यानी कि फाइंड
करेंगे कि भैया कौन-कौन से मेल सर्वर्स
हैं? पब्लिक आईपीस निकालने की कोशिश
करेंगे। कौन-कौन सी पब्लिक आईपीस हैं? सो
दैट दे कैन प्लान द अटैक।
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चरल लेआउट क्या है? किस
तरीके से नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चरल लेआउट
हमारा काम कर रहा है? या उस नेटवर्क का
काम कर रहा है? यह पता लगाने की कोशिश
करेंगे। डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड इनमरेशन एंड
डीएनएस के जितने भी रिकॉर्ड्स हैं जैसे ए
रिकॉर्ड, एमएक्स रिकॉर्ड या आपका सी नेम
रिकॉर्ड या आपका
डबल ए डबल ए रिकॉर्ड या आपका टीएक्सटी
रिकॉर्ड जितने भी रिकॉर्ड्स हैं वो सब
फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेंगे। ये डीएनएस
फुटप्रिंटिंग के थ्रू करने का कोशिश करेगा
जो भी अटैकर होगा। सो दैट गेट टू गेट द
मैक्सिमम इनेशन। अब ये सब डोमेन इनमरेशन
कैसे होती है? तो देखो डीएनएस इनमरेशन के
थ्रू भी डीएनएस ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के थ्रू भी
सब सब डोमेनस इनमरेट किए जाते हैं। अब यह
एक गेसिंग का काम हो जाता है। बेसिकली गेस
वर्क हो जाता है। अगर आप में से जितने लोग
यहां पे प्रेजेंट हैं अगर आप में से कोई
बग बाउंटी का स्टूडेंट है या बग बाउंट
करता है। बग बाउंट में इंटरेस्ट रखता है
तो उसे डीएनएस ब्रूट फ़ोर्सिंग के बारे में
पता होगा। या डीएनएस के थ्रू डीएनएस ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स करके सबडोमेन फाइंड करने का पता
होगा। कितने लोग हैं आपको? आप में से यहां
पे जिनको डीएनएस ब्रूड फोर्सिंग करके
सबडोमेन फाइंड करने का आईडिया है या करते
भी हैं। हाउ मेनी ऑफ़ यू आर हियर?
लेट मी नो।
किसी ने किया है?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आई नो। ओके।
ठीक है।
हां, बग बंटी में मैंने भी बताया हुआ है
सिद्धार्थ। ओके। ठीक है। ओके। कुछ लोग
करते हैं यहां पे। तो डीएनएस के थ्रू क्या
होता है? गेसिंग का काम होता है। बेसिकली
डीएनएस का डीएनएस ब्रड फोर्सिंग जब करते
हैं आईपी रिॉल्व आईपी रिज़ॉल्वर्स का यूज़
करके हम एक सबडोमेन के थ्रू एक नॉर्मल
वेबसाइट या नॉर्मल डोमेन का डिफरेंट
सबडोमेन फाइंड करने की कोशिश करते हैं या
सब डोमेनस के भी सब डोमेनस फाइंड करने की
कोशिश करते हैं। रूट फ़ोर्स करके उससे
इंटरनल सबडोमेनस निकालने की कोशिश करते
हैं। लेवल थ्री, लेवल फोर, लेवल फाइव के
सबडोमेन जो होते हैं उनको फाइंड करने की
कोशिश करते हैं। यह एक गेस वर्क भी होता
है कि ले जैसे कि मान लो कि अह मान लो कि
admin.com.com है। ठीक है? अब इसका कोई एक
इंटरनल सर्विस का सबडोमेन चल रहा है जिसका
इस जिसका क्या है? जिसका सबडोमेन क्या है?
vpn.min.com
अब ये कोई सेंसिटिव सबडोमेन हो सकता है।
यानी कि एक वीpए सर्विस है जिसका कोई
एडमिन पोर्टल लग रहा है। जनरली ये सब
डोमेनस जो है हो सकता है नॉर्मल सबडोमेन
इनरेशन में आपको ना मिले। बट डीएनएस ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग करके सबडोमेन जब फाइंड करेंगे तो
पॉसिबिलिटीज बढ़ जाती हैं सबडोमेनस फाइंड
करने की। तो ऐसी सेंसिटिव सबडोमेनस जो
बहुत छिपी हुई सब डोमेनस है लेवल फोर फाइव
के डेप्थ के सबडोमेनस हैं उनको फाइंड करने
के लिए डीएनएस ब्रूड फोर्सिंग का यूज़ किया
जाता है। एंड उसी को बेसिकली यहां पे
सबडोमेन इनमरेशन किया जाता है डीएनएस
फुटप्रिंटिंग के थ्रू। तो ये भी एक अटैकर
का काम हो सकता है। बाकी चीजें आपको मैंने
बता दी। ठीक है? यह सारी चीजें हैं। अब
देखो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां नेटवर्किंग का पार्ट आपका कंप्लीट है।
अब डीआरएस फुटप्रिंटिंग में ही एसओसी
इंडिकेटर की अगर हम बात करें तो अगर आपको
एज अ एसओसी एल1 आपको कुछ इस तरीके के
लॉग्स दिख रहे हैं। जहां पे आपको अलग-अलग
सब डोमेनस दिख रहे हैं। एडमिन वाली, डेव
वाली, वीपीए वाली, टेस्ट वाली। तो ये
नॉर्मल यूजर बिहेवियर नहीं हो सकता है।
दिस कैन बी अ रिकॉन और डीएनएस
फुटप्रिंटिंग। यह एक फ्रुट प्रिंटिंग हो
सकता है या रेकॉन हो सकता है। डीएनएस
फुटप्रिंटिंग हो सकता है। तो इसको आपको
ध्यान रखना है। अगर अटैका सक्सेसफुल हो
जाता है तो उसको उसके पास सारे सबडोमेनस
हो सकते हैं। पूरा डीएनएस का स्ट्रक्चर हो
सकता है। इंटरनल नेमिंग पैटर्न हो सकता
है। इंटरनल सेंसिटिव सबडोमेनस हो सकते
हैं। इंटरनल पाथ डिस्क्लोज़र हो सकता है।
एंड बहुत कुछ हो सकता है। सो बेसिकली ये
पूरा का पूरा इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर लीकेज हो
जाएगा। आपके इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर आपकी कैसे
काम कर रही है? किस तरीके से आपका जो
डोमेन रिॉल्व हो रहा है, किन आईपीस पे या
पब्लिक आईपीस कौन सी हैं? इंटरनल आईपीस
कौन सी हैं? इंटरनल सब डोमेनस कौन सी हैं?
बहुत सेंसिटिव से इंटरनल सब डोमेनस कौन
है? ये सब रिवील हो जाएगा। एंड जब ये सब
रिवील हो जाएगा तो अटैकर के लिए काफी आसान
हो जाएगा अपने इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने के लिए। बस सिंपल सा
फंडा है। तो इसको हमेशा ध्यान रखना है कि
डीएनएस जो फुटप्रिंटिंग है उससे आपको अपने
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को बचाना है कि अटैकर जो है
डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग बहुत इन डेप्थ ना कर
पाए। उससे आपको अपना डिफेंस जो है वो
स्टार्ट करके रखना है। अपना डिफेंस वहां
पे एग्जीक्यूट करना है। राइट? हां ज़ोन
ट्रांसफर भी।
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देखिए एस
डीएनएस फुटिंग फुटप्रिंटिंग में अगर हम
एसओसी डिटेक्शन की बात करें फुटप्रिंटिंग
में तो क्या हो सकते हैं? की इंडिकेटर्स
क्या-क्या हो सकते हैं? हाई नंबर ऑफ
डीएनएस क्वरीज फ्रॉम वन आईपी। अगर एक ही
आईपी से आपको बहुत सारे डीएनएस क्वेरीज आ
रहे हैं, तो यह एक बहुत चैलेंजिंग एंड
बहुत ही अलर्ट रहने वाला चीज आपको शो करता
है। सीक्वेंशियल सबडोमेनिक क्वरीज़ बहुत एक
बहुत मतलब फ्रीक्वेंट सीक्वेंस में सब
डोमेनस की क्वेरीज़ आ रहे हैं। एक के एक के
बाद एक वो भी एक अलर्ट आपको जो है वो थोड़ी
सी अलर्ट रहने की जरूरत है वहां पे।
अनयूजुअल एक्सटर्नल आईपी क्वरिंग मेनी
डोमेनस। अब बाहर की कोई अनयूजुअल आईपी है।
कुछ ऐसी ऐसी आईपी जो आपको यूज़ुअल नहीं लग
रही। नॉर्मल नहीं लग रही है। एंड वो
डोमेनस को क्वेरी कर रहे हैं। तो वो भी जो
है एक आपका इंडिकेटर होता है एसओसी के तौर
पे। आपको इन बातों का भी ध्यान रखना
चाहिए। एग्जांपल
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] के तौर पे सर
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग क्या होता है? अरे रुको
तो सही। अभी तो स्टार्ट किया है। रुको तो
सही। जस्ट जस्ट वेट राइट। सर आप प्लीज
बाइनरी एक्सप्लॉयटेशन के लिए कोई
प्लेलिस्ट बनाइए ना। कोई कोर्स टाइप सर?
बाइनरी एक्सप्लॉयटेशन का कोर्स YouTube पे
नहीं आ सकता है ब्रदर। उसका जब भी आएगा
पेड ट्रेनिंग आएगा। YouTube पे वह आने का
मतलब है YouTube पे YouTube से उसको हटा
दिया जाएगा। मस्ट मस्ट प्रोबेबबली हटा
दिया जा सकता है। कई लोगों के साथ हुआ भी
है। कई कई सारे वीडियोस तो खैर हैं बट
स्टिल हट जाते हैं कई सारे तो वो दिक्कत
वाली चीज़ है। तो उसकी जब भी आएगी पेड
कोर्सर्सेस ही आएंगी अगर आनी भी होगी तो।
ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एग्जांपल के
तौर पे मान लो एक सोर्स IP है 45.12 डॉट
समथिंग समथिंग समथिंग समथिंग और ये
क्वेरीज कर रही हैं आपके इन सब डोमेनस को
admin company.com VPN mail dv.com
तो यहां पे सामने वाला जो है एक्टिव
रिक्गोसेंस कर रहा है। यानी कि डीएनएस
फुटप्रिंटिंग कर रहा है। दिस फॉल्स अंडर द
एक्टिव रिकॉनसेंस। क्योंकि आप इंटरेक्ट
करते हैं। सामने पर्टिकुलर जो सर्वर्स
हैं, जो कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं उनसे इंटरेक्ट
कर रहे हैं। सो इट्स कम अंडर द एक्टिव
रिकॉनसेंस। तो इस तरीके का अगर कुछ
एग्जांपल आपको मिले तो यहां पे आप समझिएगा
कि यहां पे एक्टिव रिकॉनसेंस यानी कि
डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग होने के चांसेस आपके
हैं। अब देखिए अब इसी में आपका आता है
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग। दिस इज़ द थिंग डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग। जो कि अभी कुछ लोग पूछ रहे थे
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग क्या होता है? तो देखो जब
डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग की बात हम करते हैं
तो डीएनएस पोइजनिंग भी हम यहां पे जानना
चाहेंगे। डीएनएस पोइजनिंग का मतलब सिंपल
सा होता है इंजेक्टिंग फेक डीएनएस
रिस्पांससेस। बस फेक डीएनएस रिस्पांस को
इंजेक्ट करना। यानी कि डोमेन से पहले जो
IP पे आपका रिज़ॉल्व हो रहा था। यानी कि
अगर हम Google.com ओपन कर रहे थे तो वो
Google.com के ओरिजिनल IP पे ही रिज़ॉल्व
हो रहा था। यानी कि उस डोमेन के लिए
Google का ओरिजिनल IP ढूंढ के लाया जा रहा
था। हमारा डीएनएस ला रहा था। अब क्या
होगा? होगा जब हम डीएनएस पोइजनिंग करेंगे
तो अगर हम google.com को ओपन करेंगे तो अब
हमारे उस google.com के लिए एक फेक IPपी
ढूंढ के लाया जाएगा डीएनएस की तरफ से
क्योंकि हमारा डीएनएस कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो
चुका है। हमारा डीएनएस पोइजनंड हो चुका
है। हमारे डीएनएस में जहर घुल चुका है।
हमारे डीएनएस में किसी ना के इंजेक्ट कर
दिया है। गलत चीजें। गलत आईपीस डाल दी
हैं। जिस डोमेन का जो आईपी होना चाहिए
उसके जगह पे फर्जी या मलशियस आईपी डाल दी
गई है जो कि अटैकर की आईपी हो सकती है।
अटैकर कंट्रोलोल्ड आईपी हो सकती है। एंड
वहीं जब डोमेन क्या करेगा रॉन्ग आईपी पे
रीडायरेक्ट कर देगा यानी खोलेंगे तो आप
google.com लेकिन वो रीडायरेक्ट कर देगा
एक दूसरी आईपी पे जिस पे कि कोई और ही चीज
होस्टेड होगी किसी हो सकता है उस
पर्टिकुलर Google का ही एक क्लोन पेज हो।
एक सिंपल हूबहू दिखता एकदम सिमिलर पेज हो
जो कि एक फिशिंग पेज हो जहां से आपके
क्रेडेंशियल चुराए जाने की कोशिश की जा
रही हो। आपके आइडेंटिटी चुराए जाने की
कोशिश की जा रही हो। आपके क्रेडिट कार्ड
के डिटेल्स चुराई जाने की कोशिश की जा रही
हो या आपके सेंसिटिव सेंसिटिव इनेशन चुराई
जाने की कोशिश की जा रही हो। ये सब कुछ हो
सकता है। फिशिंग अटैक जो है इस तरीके से
स्पेयर फिशिंग या नॉर्मल फिशिंग अटैक इस
तरीके से ल्च किया जाता है। तो डीएनएस का
यूज़ करके। तो इसका मतलब होता है डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग। यह डीएनएस पोइजनिंग आप लोगों
में से कई लोग पूछ रहे थे कि इसका गोल
क्या है? रीडायरेक्ट यूजर्स टू फेक
वेबसाइट। फेक वेबसाइट पे रीडायरेक्ट करना,
क्रेडेंशियल्स चुराना, मैलवेयर को डिलीवर
करना। तो अब आई थिंक डीएनएस पोइजनिंग आप
में से सबको समझ में आ गया आ चुका होगा कि
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग एक्सैक्टली क्या होता है?
बहुत सिंपल में मैंने बताया। अभी तक बहुत
लोगों को कॉम्प्लेक्स लग रहा था। काफी लोग
इसमें पूछ रहे थे कि भाई डीएनएस पोइजनिंग
क्या होता है? लोगों को लग रहा था डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग भाई होती क्या है? अब समझ में आ
गया डीएनएस पोइजनिंग क्या होती है? आर यू
गेटिंग?
बताइए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
रिस्पांस काफी कम लोगों का आता है। मुझे
रिस्पांस सभी लोग क्यों सब लोग करेंगे ना
मजा आएगा। प्लीज आप सभी लोग रिसोंड कीजिए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एवरीवन रिसोंड प्लीज
गेटिंग द पॉइंट। ठीक है। अच्छी बात है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है। गॉट। ये डीएनएस पोइजनिंग आपकी
होती है। ओके। अब इसको हम थोड़ा और अच्छे
से समझेंगे। वी विल अंडरस्टैंड दिस इन अ
मोर ग्रेट वे।
यहां पे आपको सबको दिख रहा है ये? इमेज
आपको क्लियर दिख रही है? एक बार मुझे बता
दीजिए सभी लोग। अगर आपको इमेज दिख रही है
तो बता दीजिए। नहीं दिख रही है तो आप अपने
YouTube की स्क्रीन को ज़ूम भी कर सकते
हैं। आप अपने YouTube की स्क्रीन को पिंच
करके ज़ूम भी कर सकते हैं। तो आपको दिखेगी।
दिख रही है सबको इमेज?
बता दीजिए। फटाफट बताइए।
ओके। अगर नहीं दिख रही है तो ऐसे पिंच
करना स्क्रीन को। मोबाइल पे अगर हो तो ऐसे
ज़ूम करना। या लैपटॉप पे भी हो तो अपनी
पूरी ब्राउज़र के ब्राउज़र को ही जो बड़ा
करते हैं ना ज़ूम करते हैं वैसे भी कर सकते
हो। ठीक है? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब देखो डीएनएस पोइजनिंग मैं यहां पे आपको
समझाता हूं। एक इमेज के थ्रू बहुत इजी वे
में समझाऊंगा आपको। ठीक है? ताकि आपको
ज्यादा कॉम्प्लेक्स ना लगे। अगर मैं ऐसे
बताता तो आपको शायद कॉम्प्लेक्स लगता। बट
ये मैं बहुत ईजी वे में बताऊंगा। डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग इज़ एन अटैक वेयर फॉल्स देखो यहां
पे दिया हुआ है वेयर फॉल्स डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड्स आर इंजेक्टेड इंटू अ डीएनएस
रिज़ॉल्वर्स कैश रीडायरेक्टिंग यूज़र्स टू
मलशियस वेबसाइट। अब डीएनएस का रिज़ॉल्वर
कैश होता है। देखो जब भी कोई सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर होता है उसका एक कैश मेमोरी भी
होता है। तो जैसे मान लो कि हमारा जब आई
हम जब डोमेन डालते हैं तो उस डोमेन को
आईपी में कन्वर्ट करने के लिए डीएनएस काम
करता है। तो अब डीएनएस बार-बार थोड़ी ना
सारे रूट सर्वर आपका जो होता है टीएलडी
सर्वर्स ऑथॉरिटी नेम सर्वर्स के पास जाके
बार-बार आपकी उस आईपी को लेकर आएगा। वो
अपना भी एक कैश मेमोरी रखेगा जहां पे
स्टोर रखेगा। वो स्टोर रखेगा। कुछ डोमेनस
के आईपीस को ऑलरेडी स्टोर करके रखेगा। तो
नेक्स्ट टाइम जब भी आप वापस से उससे पूछने
जाओगे कि भैया इस डोमेन का आईपी क्या है?
तो वो अपने कैश मेमोरी से जहां पे स्टोर
करके रखा है वहां से निकाल के आपको दे
देगा। तो अब डीएनएस पोइजिंग में क्या होता
है? जो अटैकर होता है उसी कैश जो डीएनएस
का रिजॉल्वर्स कैश मेमोरी होता है डीएनएस
रिज़ॉल्वर का आपका उसी कैश मेमोरी को
इनफेक्ट कर देता है। वहां पे फालतू की
आईपी डाल देगा एक डोमेन के लिए और जब
सामने से रिक्वेस्ट आएगा उस डोमेन के लिए
तो वहीं फर्जी आईपी उसको सर्व कर दिया
जाएगा। एंड जो यूजर है वो फर्जी आईपी पे
रीडायरेक्ट हो जाएगा। एज सिंपल एज दैट।
बस इतना ही सिंपल था। अब देखिए नॉर्मल
डीएनएस रेोल्यूशन में क्या होता है? पहले
उसको देखते हैं। पहले हमारे सबसे पहले
स्टेप में क्या हो जाता है? एक कोई एक
डोमेन पे क्वेरी होती है रूट सर्वर के
पास। फिर जो होता है क्या होता है आपका
रेफर टू.com TLD सर्वर यहां पे। ओके? फिर
यहां पे थर्ड क्वेरी टीएलडी सर्वर से होती
है। फिर ऑथरेटिव नेम सर्वर से रेफर कर
दिया जाता है। फिर फिफ्थ क्वेरी जो होती
है वो ऑथरेटिव नेम सर्वर से होती है। एंड
यहां पे ऑथरेटिव नेम सर्वर जो है आपका
होस्टिंग प्रोवाइडर होता है जो लास्ट का
एक हायरार्की में सबसे लास्ट वाला होता है
जिसके पास एकदम होता ही होता है। ये एक
ऐसा बंदा है घर का मालिक है जिसके पास
चाबी होनी ही होनी है। इसके पास नहीं है
तो इसका मतलब भाई गड़बड़ है कुछ। तो बाद
में यह ऑथॉरिटी नेम सब क्या करता है? आईपी
को रिटर्न कर देता है। हमारे डीएनएस
रिजॉल्वर को रिकर्सिव जो जिसको रिकर्सिव
रिजॉल्वर्स बोलते हैं। इसको हम IP को
रिटर्न कर देता है। तो अब क्या होगा कि
यूजर जो है ये कनेक्ट कर लेगा रियल
ऑथेंटिक जो हमारी वेबसाइट है या आईपी है
उससे लेजिटमेट वेबसाइट से जो है हमारा
कनेक्शन यूजर का हो जाएगा। यह तो एक
ऑथेंटिक डीएनएस कनेक्शन हो गया जो मैंने
पहले भी बताया था।
ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके फॉर स्कल ठीक है एक बार आप रिकॉर्डिंग
जरूर देखिएगा अब डीएनएस पोइजनिंग में क्या
होता है पहला जो हमारा स्टेप होता है देखो
इस स्टेप को समझना यहां पे पहला स्टेप
होता है अटैकर सेंड्स मेनी फेक डीएनएस
रिस्पांससेस यूजुअली वि गेस्ट
गेस्ट सोर्स पोर्ट एंड आईडी यहां पे आपका
जो
यूजर होता है जो बेसिकली जो एक अटैकर होता
है वो क्या करता है बहुत सारे फेक डीएनएस
रिस्पांससेस भेजता
डीएनएस रिज़ॉल्वर कैसेस को बहुत सारे फेक
रिस्पांससेस भेजता है। अब क्या हो जाता
है? वन मशियस रिस्पांस इज़ एक्सेप्टेड एंड
कैश। अब बहुत सारे जब रिस्पों्ससेस भेजे
जाते हैं ना तो उसमें से एक जो मलेशियस
रिस्पांस है उसको एक्सेप्ट कर लिया जाता
है हमारे किसके द्वारा? डीएनएस रिज़ॉल्वर
के द्वारा। और उसको अपने कैश मेमोरी में
रख लिया जाता है। जैसे कि अब एग्जांपल.com
यहां पे एग्जांपल.com इज़ इक्वल टू यहां पे
क्या कर लिया गया? 6.6.6.6
ये आईपी दे दी गई। अब मान लो कि कोई एक
जेन्युइन वेबसाइट है example.com एक डोमेन
है। अब इसके जगह पे ये IP दे दी गई
6.6.6.6
ये आईपी दे दी गई। तो ये जो डीएनएस
रिजॉल्वर है इसके पास कैश हो जाता है।
इसके कैश मेमोरी में जाके ये फिट हो जाता
है। हटाकर ऐसे बहुत सारे बहुत सारे ऐसे जो
आईपी एंड डोमेन का एक रिस्पांस है वो
डीएनएस को भेजता रहेगा कि भैया ये लो ये
एक्सेप्ट करो। ये लो ये एक्सेप्ट करो।
डीएनएस रिज़ॉल्वर्स जो होते हैं यूज़ली उसको
रिजेक्ट करते रहते हैं। बोले ना भाई यह
कौन सा है? यह क्या दे रहे हो तुम? बट
उसमें से बहुत सारे जब रिस्पांससेस जब
जाते हैं फेक डीएनएस रिस्पांससेस तो किसी
एक डीएनएस रिस्पांस को या मल्टीपल डीएनएस
रिस्पांस को हमारे डीएनएस रिज़ॉल्वर जो
होता है क्या करता है उसको एक्सेप्ट कर
लेता है कई बार ऐसी होती है ड्यू टू मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन ड्यू टू डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ
प्रॉब्लम्स इशूज़ एंड उस केस में वो अपने
कैश मेमोरी में उसको रख लेती है। अब जब एक
फेक एंट्री हो गई है example.com के लिए
6.6.6.6
तो अब क्या होगा देखो अब यहां पे जो हमारा
यूजर है वो example.com क्वरी करेगा dns
रिज़ॉल्वर कैश से। अब क्योंकि यह तो
डिॉल्वर कैश है। इसमें example.com का
6.6.6.6 है। जबकि मान लो रियल IPपी होनी
चाहिए अगर 11.1.1.1
ये रियल IPपी होनी चाहिए मान लो
example.com की। बट रिज़ॉल्वर कैश में
6.6.6.6 IP है। अब जब ये रिक्वेस्ट आएगी
example.com की यूजर के साइट से तो हमारा
रिज़ॉल्वर कैश जो है तुरंत रिस्पॉन्स
रिस्पांस करेगा किस चीज़ से? 6.6.6.6 है और
यूजर जो है फेक वेबसाइट पे रीडायरेक्ट हो
जाएगा और एक फेक वेबसाइट ओपन हो जाएगी। इस
तरीके से यूजर को जहां 11.1.1.1 पे जाना
चाहिए था अब वो 6.6.6.6
पे जा रहा है। क्योंकि हमारे हटाकर भैया
ने डीएनएस को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया है।
डीएनएस को पोइजन कर दिया था। एंड रिज़ॉल्व
कैश में एक पोइजन एंट्री थी। जहां पे एक
डोमेन एक रियल डोमेन के लिए एक फेक आईपी
का वहां पे स्टोरेज हो चुका था। ये पूरा
का पूरा डीएनएस पोइजनिंग का फ्लो है। आई
होप आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। राइट? आर यू
गेटिंग?
हां, दिस इज पॉसिबल इफ देयर इज सम डीएनएस
मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन, कोई डीएनएस फॉलोबिलिटी
है, कोई वीकनेसेस है, तभी पॉसिबल है।
देखो, आप कोई भी अटैक लिसन अ चित्रलेखा
कोई भी अटैक तभी भी होती तभी होती है।
किसी भी दुनिया में कोई भी अटैक दो ही
सिनेरियोस में होती है। एक अगर सामने वाला
सिस्टम वनरेबल है, उसमें कोई वीकनेस है,
कोई वनेबिलिटी है। दूसरी, या तो आपने कोई
वनेरेबिलिटी फाइंड कर ली है एक सिक्योर
सिस्टम में, और फिर आप उसको एक्सप्लोइट कर
रहे हो। दोनों केस में ही ओनली सिस्टम पे
या किसी भी तरह के मशीन पे अटैक होता है।
अदरवाइज उस मशीन या सिस्टम पे अटैक होना
इंपॉसिबल है। तो जब भी कोई अटैक को हम
मानते हैं, जब भी हम कोई अटैक को अस्यूम
करते हैं, तो हम मानते हैं कि दैट कुड बी
अ वलनेरेबल मशीन। दैट कुड बी अ वलनेरेबल
सर्विस। आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग अ चित्रलेखा।
आर यू गेटिंग?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ यू आर गेटिंग।
ओके।
अंडरस्टुड
ठीक है। ठीक है। तो ये हमारा डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग का अटैक फ्लो है। आई होप कि आपको
डायग्राम के थ्रू क्लियर आपको समझ में आया
होगा। थोड़ा सा क्लियर हुआ होगा डायग्राम
के थ्रू। क्लियर हुआ है?
समझ आ गया? ईजी था।
अब नेक्स्ट पे आते हैं यहां पे। अब यहां
पे टेक्निकल व्यू समझते हैं। अभी तो आपने
डीएनएस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पोइजनिंग
देखा या डीएनएस पोइजनिंग बोलो या डीएनएस
कैश पोइजनिंग बोलो। क्योंकि रिज़ॉल्व कैश
को पोइजन कर दिया जाता है। रिज़ॉल्व कैश
में पोइज़न एंट्री होती है। तो उसको डीएनएस
कैश पोइजनिंग भी बोल सकते हो। इसका
टेक्निकल व्यू थोड़ा सा समझ लेते हैं। देन
इसके एग्जांपल सिनेरियो देख लेंगे। देन
टाइप्स वगैरह देख लेंगे। सब कुछ देख
लेंगे। ठीक है? तो हमारा यहां पे नेक्स्ट
जो यहां पे है यह है हाउ डीएनएस कैश
पोइजनिंग वर्क्स। टेक्निकल व्यू इसका
देखते हैं। देखो
ओके। पहला स्टेप है अटैकर सेंड्स अ डीएनएस
क्वेरी टू द रिज़ॉल्वर। अटैकर एक डीएनएस
क्वेरी रिज़ॉल्वर को भेजता है। रिज़ॉल्वर
फॉरवर्ड्स द क्वेरी टू द ऑथरेटिव सर्वर।
ऑथरेटिव सर्वर को भेज देते हैं ये। बिफोर
द लेजिटमेट रिस्पांस अराइव्स। अटैकर
सेंड्स मल्टीपल फेक रिस्पांससेस विथ गेस्ट
डिटेल्स। अब देखो अटैकर क्या करता है पहले
डीएनएस को करी भेजेगा कि भैया ए बी सी
जैसे पिछले बार में हमने यहां देखा कि
अटैकर क्या करता है फेक डीएनएस
रिस्पांससेस भेजता है हमारे डीएनएस
रिजॉल्वर को तो क्यों भेजता है ये क्योंकि
अटैकर पहले क्या कर चुका होता है कि
डीएनएस क्वेरी भेजता है जैसे नॉर्मल यूजर
डीएनएस क्वेरी भेजते हैं कि googlecom का
IP भैया google.com ओपन करना है वैसे ही
यह एक क्वेरी भेजता है Google के लिए मान
लो। अब रिजॉल्वर उस क्वेरी को आगे की तरफ
फॉरवर्ड कर देता है। अब जैसे आगे ऑथॉरिटिव
नेम सर्वर से रियल एंट्री आएगी उसके पहले
ही हमारे अटैकर भैया जो हैं वो मल्टीपल
फेक रिस्पांससेस भेजने शुरू कर देते हैं।
जो कि हमने इस स्टेप में देखा था पहले
स्टेप में मल्टीपल फेक रिस्पांससेस का। ये
मल्टीपल फेक रिस्पांससेस भेजने लगते हैं।
अब जब ये मल्टीपल फेक रिस्पों्ससेस भेजते
हैं उसमें से कोई एक रिस्पांस बाय चांस जो
है वो क्या हो जाता है रिज़ॉल्वर कैश के
अंदर स्टोर हो जाती है। जो कि बेसिकली
क्या कहा जाता है? आपका कैश पोइजनिंग हो
गया। आपका जो रिज़ॉल्वर कैश है उसको पोइज़न
एंट्री के साथ पोइजन कर दिया गया। वो वहां
पे पोइज़न हो गया। अब इफ वन फेक रिस्पांस
मैचेस द एक्सपेक्टेड डिटेल्स रिज़ॉल्वर्स
एक्सेप्ट इट एंड स्ट इन द कैश। अगर एक फेक
रिस्पांस अब जैसे डीएनएस रिस्पों्ससेस
अटैकर थाउज़ेंड्स ऑफ़ रिस्पों्ससेस भेज रहा
है। उसमें से एक रिस्पांस भी वो गेस पे
भेज रहा है। गेस कर रहा है और कुछ भी नहीं
हो रहा। उसमें से एक रिस्पांस भी अगर बाय
चांस मैच कर जाता है उस पर्टिकुलर डोमेन
के लिए तो उसको स्टोर कर लिया जाता है
रिजॉल्व कैश के अंदर में एंड फ्यूचर
क्वेरीज यूजज़ द पोइजन कैश एंड रिटर्न द
फेक आईपी। उसके बाद जो भी फ्यूचर में
दूसरे लेजिटमेट यूज़र्स क्वरी करेंगे तो उन
केस में क्या होगा कि पोइजन कैश होगी और
वहां से एक फेक आईपी पे रीडायरेक्ट किया
जाएगा उस डोमेन के लिए। दैट्स इट। इसको हम
डीएनएस स्पुफिंग या डीएनएस कैश पोइजनिंग
या डीएनएस पोइजनिंग भी बोलते हैं। ठीक है?
हां देखो डीएनए स्पुफिंग जो है वो काइंड
ऑफ तुम बोल सकते हो नो थिंग कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है।
हां ठीक है अब ये समझ में आ गया अब देखो
एग्जांपल सिनेरियो की अगर मैं बात करूं
यहां पे यू वांट टू विजिट www.bank.com
मान लो आप bank.com पे विजिट करना चाहते
हो। अटैकर पोइजनंस डीएनएस रिज़ॉल्वर विद
फेक एंट्री। एंट्री अटैकर ने फेक एंट्री
से डीएनएस रिज़ॉल्वर को पोइजन कर दिया है।
द बैंक रिज़ॉल्व्स टू 6.6.6.6
अटैकर की आईपी पे रिज़ॉल्व हो रहा है। नाउ
बैंक यू लैंड ऑन अ फेक बैंक वेबसाइट। अब
उस 6.6.6.6
IP पे एक फेक वेबसाइट होस्टेड है। देखो
कोई भी IP पे एक वेबसाइट होस्टेड होती है।
यानी कि हर वेबसाइट का एक IP होता है। तो
बैकग्राउंड में IP पे ही होस्टेड होती है
वेबसाइट। वह तो आपको बस याद रखने के लिए
या याद इसलिए ईज़ली हो जाए तो हम डोमेन को
यूज़ करते हैं। तो अब एक फेक बैंक वेबसाइट
पे रीडायरेक्ट हो जाता है नॉर्मल यूज़र। अब
आप वहां पे इंटरनेट बैंकिंग के
क्रेडेंशियल्स या क्रेडिट कार्ड की
डिटेल्स डालते हैं एंड अटैकर जो है आपकी
डाटा को चुरा लेता है या आपकी जो भी इनेशन
है उसको चुरा लेता है। इस तरीके से ये
पूरा का पूरा सिनेरियो काम करता है। अब
इसी में यहां पे तीन टाइप के डीएनएस के
पोइजनिंग होते हैं। तीन टाइप के पोइजनिंग
होते हैं। देयर आर थ्री टाइप्स ऑफ डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग। पहला आपका होता है कैश
पोइजनिंग, दूसरा आपका होता है होस्ट फाइल
पोइजनिंग। तीसरा आपका होता है राउटर
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग। तीन तरीके की चीज़ होती
है। तीनों को मैं आपको
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
थोड़ा समझाता हूं। देखो कैश पोइजनिंग क्या
होता है? जो अभी आपने देखा मलेशियस डेटा
इज़ इंजेक्टेड इनू डीएनएस रिज़ॉल्व कैश
मोस्ट कॉमन एंड डेंजरस। जो अभी हमने देखा
वो डीएनएस कैश पोइजनिंग ही है। इसको
समझाने की जरूरत नहीं है। होस्ट फाइल
पोइजनिंग। अब ये क्या होती है? अटैकर
मॉडिफाई द लोकल होस्ट फाइल टू रीडायरेक्ट
डोमेनस टू मलेशियस आईपी। अब आपकी एक लोकल
ना होस्ट फाइल होती है। आप सबको पता है
होस्ट फाइल कहां होती है? Windows के अंदर
में मैं आपको अगर नहीं पता तो दिखाना
चाहूंगा। Windows के अंदर में
सी ड्राइव जहां पे आपकी Windows इंस्टॉल्ड
होती है। इसमें आप Windows में जाओगे।
देन सिस्टम 32 में जाओगे।
देन ड्राइवर्स में जाओगे।
देन ईटीसी में जाओगे देन यहां आपको
मिलेंगे होस्ट्स होस्ट नाम से एक फाइल
मिलेगी इस फाइल को जब ओपन करोगे मान लो
मैं यहां पे ओपन विद कर देता हूं नोटपड
चलो नोटपड कर देते हैं तो कुछ इस तरीके की
ये आपको फाइल दिखती है राइट
मैं इसको छोटा कर देता हूं यहां पे इस
तरीके की कुछ फाइल दिखती है अब यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे ये देखो यहां
पे देखो ये क्या है ये दिस इज़ अ सैंपल
होस्ट फाइल फाइल यूज़्ड बाय Microsoft TCP
आईपी फॉर Windows। ठीक है? दिस फाइल
कंटेन्स द मैपिंग्स ऑफ़ IP एड्रेसेस टू द
होस्ट नेम्स। यानी कि बेसिकली होस्ट नेम्स
बोलो, डोमेन नेम्स बोलो, सेम है। ईच
एंट्री शुड बी केप्ट ऑन एन इंडिविजुअल
लाइन। हर एंट्री एक इंडिविजुअल लाइन पे
होनी चाहिए। द IPपी एड्रेस शुड बी प्लेस्ड
इन द फर्स्ट कॉलम। पहले कॉलम पे आपका IPपी
एड्रेस होना चाहिए। फॉललोड बाय द
कॉस्पोंडिंग होस्ट नेम। उसके बाद आपका
डोमेन नेम होना चाहिए। द IPपी एड्रेस एंड
द होस्ट नेम शुड बी सेपरेटेड बाय एटलीस्ट
वन स्पेस। एक स्पेस से दोनों सेपरेट होने
चाहिए। एडिशनली कमेंट्स सच ऐज़ दीज़ यह
कमेंट्स हैं जिसके स्टार्टिंग में हैश लगे
हैं जिनका कोई मतलब नहीं होता है। मे बी
इंसर्टेड ऑन इंडिविजुअल लाइंस और फॉलोइंग
द मशीन नेम डिनोटेड बाय अ हैश सिंबल। सी
सिंपल हैश की तरह। तो इसी तरीके से आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे कुछ एंट्री जो हैड्ड है
अभी ये काम की नहीं है। मतलब इनको
एक्टिवेट नहीं किया गया है। इसका मतलब
क्या है यहां पे? देखो यहां पे सिंपल सा
आप सुनो। यह जो IP है इस डोमेन पे मैप की
मैप की गई है। इसका मतलब यही है दिस IP इज
मैप्ड टू दिस डोमेन। यानी कि इस IP को ओपन
करने पे ये डोमेन आपकी ओपन होगी या ये
डोमेन इस IP पे रिज़ॉल्व होगा। सिंपल सा
मतलब ये है कि ये जो डोमेन है इस IP पे
रिज़ॉल्व होगा। अब यहीं पे अगर हम एक लोकल
डीएनएस के लिए हम यहां पे होस्ट फाइल
मॉडिफिकेशन कर दें। एंड इसमें हम Google
की IP के लिए कुछ और डाल दें। लेट्स सपोज
वी आर एंटरिंग यहां पे Google.com और IP
में यहां पे हम अ एक दो मतलब कुछ भी
1.1.2.2 ऐसे करके डाल दें। तो इसका मतलब
है इस Google डॉट को डॉट को आपको इस IP पे
मैप करनी है ना कि उसके ओरिजिनल आईपी पे।
तो यहां पे होस्ट फाइल मॉडिफिकेशन के थ्रू
क्या हो जाता है भैया आपका? यहां पे एक
अटैक होती है जिसका नाम हम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बोलते हैं होस्ट
फाइल पोइजनिंग। ये भी एक डीएनएस पॉइजनिंग
का ही आपका पार्ट होता है। चलिए ये आपको
समझ में आ गया। दूसरा है राउटर डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग। अब राउटर डीएनएस पोइजनिंग का
मतलब है लोकल होस्ट हमेशा 127.00.1
ही होता है। दिस इज़ द रिज़र्व्ड IP 127.0
जो किसी और का नहीं होता है। लूप बैक आईपी
के लिए एक छोड़ा हुआ आईपी है। एक भटका हुआ
आईपी है जिसको कि यूज़ किया जाता है लोकल
होस्ट के लिए।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] उसके
बाद है राउटर डीएनएस पोइजनिंग। अटैकर
चेंजेस द डीएनएस सेटिंग्स ऑन द राउटर। सो
ऑल डिवाइसेस यूज़ज़ मलेशियस डीएनए। अब एक
राउटर डीएनएस पॉइजिंग होती है। यानी कि
राउटर के अंदर में भी आप क्या होते हैं?
डीएनएस की सेटिंग्स को चेंज करके एंड पूरे
के पूरे नेटवर्क गेटवे का ही डीएनएस चेंज
कर दिया आपने। यानी कि अब आपके नेटवर्क
में जितने भी डिवाइसेस कनेक्टेड हैं वो
बेसिकली क्या होगा कि आपके राउटर का जो
रियल डीएनएस गेटवे था ना जो आपका राउटर था
मान लो या कोई और डिवाइस आपने बनाया हुआ
है उसको ना यूज़ करके अब एक फेक डिवाइस के
थ्रू सारी एंट्रीज आ रही है। सारी
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है। एक फेक डीएनएस सर्वर
के थ्रू सारी रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है। यानी
कि उस पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस के पास आपकी सारी
डाटा होगी। वो स्निफ कर सकता है एंड वो
आपकी डेटा को वहां से चुरा सकता है। ठीक
है? तो ये इस तरीके की तीन तरह के ये
पोइजनिंग होते हैं। कैश पोइजनिंग, होस्ट
फाइल्स पोइजनिंग एंड राउटर डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग। ये आपको तीनों चीजें याद कर
लेनी है, समझ लेनी है। तीनों में
क्या-क्या होता है ये समझ लेना। बहुत ईजी
चीज़ है। आपको ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं होगी। कैश
पॉइजनिंग हमने बहुत डिटेल में पढ़ लिया।
होस्ट फाइल मैंने बता दी। राउटर, डीएनएस
पॉइंजिंग। राउटर के डीएनएस सेटिंग्स में
सेम जैसे आपने यहां पे किया है वैसे ही
यहां पे कैश पॉइजनिंग में वैसे ही सेम चीज़
है कि आपको डीएनएस चेंज कर देना है।
बेसिकली डीएनएस की एंट्री चेंज करनी होती
है। नथिंग एल्स बस
आई होप कि आप समझ गए होंगे। राइट? ओके। अब
यहां पे यहां पे आते हैं इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग। एसओसी का व्यू अगर एज अ
एसओसी आपका इंडिकेटर्स जो होता है वो
क्या-क्या हो सकते हैं डीएनएस पोइजनिंग के
लिए? तो पहला होगा अ डोमेन रिजॉल्व्स टू
एन अनयूजुअल और अनरिकॉग्नाइज्ड आईपी
एड्रेस। एक डोमेन जो कि अनयूजुअल और
अनरिकॉग्नाइज्ड आईपी एड्रेस पे अगर रिॉल्व
हो रहा है। एक ऐसी IPपी एड्रेस जिसके आपको
लगता है कि नहीं इस पे रिज़ॉल्व नहीं होना
चाहिए। ये गलत रिज़ॉल्व हो रहा है तो वहां
पे ये एक इंडिकेटर आपका होता है एज
एसोसिएट। आपको इसको ध्यान में रखना चाहिए।
सडन चेंज इन IP फॉर अ डोमेन दैट नॉर्मली
हैज़ अ स्टैटिक आईपी। नॉर्मली कोई डोमेन है
उसका एक स्टैटिक आईपी है। मतलब ऑलवेज
फिक्स्ड आईपी। उसमें अचानक से चेंज आपको
दिख रहा है तो वह भी एक आपका जो है एक
इंडिकेटर हो सकता है डीएनएस पोइजनिंग का।
मल्टीपल [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यूज़र्स रिपोर्टिंग सर्टिफिकेट वार्निंग्स
और वेबसाइट लुक्स डिफरेंट। कोई वेबसाइट जो
है वो थोड़ी डिफरेंट दिख रही है अब या बहुत
सारे जो यूज़र्स हैं वो बोल रहे हैं भैया
सर्टिफिकेट वार्निंग दे रहे हैं। बोल रहे
हैं कि अरे यार यहां तो कुछ गड़बड़ है यार।
सर्टिफिकेट वार्निंग आपको मिल रही है। तो
इसका मतलब वो डीएनएस पॉइजिंग का इंडिकेटर
वहां पे आपको हो सकता है। दैट कुड बी अ
डीएनएस पॉइजनिंग इंडिकेटर।
हाई नंबर ऑफ फेल्ड डीएनएस क्वरीज टू द सेम
डोमेन। कोई एक डोमेन है जहां जो कि
बेसिकली
मतलब उसके लिए आप डीएनएस क्वेरीज़ के लिए
ट्राई हो रही है। बार-बार वो फेल हो रहा
है। एक्चुअल में आईपी रिटर्न नहीं हो पा
रही है। बार-बार आपका जो डीएनएस हायरार्की
है वो फेल हो रहा है। डीएनएस क्वेरीज़ फेल
हो रहे हैं। तो इस केस में भी यहां पे
इंडिकेटर हो सकता है ये डीएनएस पोइजनिंग
का। अनयूज़ुअल एक्सटर्नल डीएनएस सर्वर्स
कम्युनिकेटिंग विथ क्लाइंट्स।
कम्युनिकेटिंग विद क्लाइंट्स। अगर बहुत
सारे क्लाइंट्स हैं, बहुत सारे अदर
डिवाइसेस हैं एंड कोई एक्सटर्नल डीएनएस
सर्वर उनसे कम्युनिकेट कर रहा है। जैसे
नॉर्मल डीएनएस सर्वर आपका जो है या गेटवे
है आपका वो ना कम्युनिकेट करके कोई बाहर
का कोई एक और आईपी है डीएनएस सर्वर है वो
कम्युनिकेशन शुरू कर चुका है। तो वहां पे
एक इंडिकेटर ये हो सकता है डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग का इन फॉर द एसओसी। राइट? दिस इज़
द थिंग। अब यहां इंपैक्ट क्या हो सकता है
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग का? भैया इंपैक्ट हो सकता
है क्रेडेंशियल थफ्ट। फिशिंग। सबसे बड़ा
इंपैक्ट हो सकता है क्रेडेंशियल थफ्ट आपका
फिशिंग के थ्रू। मैलवेयर्स को डाउनलोड
कराया जा सकता है। फेक वेबसाइट पे
रीडायरेक्ट करके आपसे मैलवेयर डाउनलोड करा
के पूरे सिस्टम को कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया जा
सकता है। फाइनेंसियल लॉसेस क्रिएट किए जा
सकते हैं। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। लॉस ऑफ़
ट्रस्ट एंड रेपुटेशन। अब कोई कंपनी है
उसके अंदर अगर इस तरह का कुछ चेंज हो जाता
है। उस कंपनी पे काफी यूज़र्स एक्टिव होते
हैं। काफी यूज़र्स उस कंपनी को ट्रस्ट करते
हैं। तो उस केस में क्या हो जाता है कि
उनका ट्रस्ट एंड रेपुटेशन लॉस हो जाता है।
रेपुटेशन खराब हो जाता है। ट्रस्ट का इशू
आ जाता है। पब्लिक सोचती है अरे यार यहां
तो पंगा ही गड़बड़ी हो रहा है। तो ये भी
एक चीज हो सकती है। राइट? प्रिवेंशन क्या
है? डिफेंसेस क्या है? इसके रिगार्डिंग तो
देखो इसका बेसिकली प्रिवेंशन का आपको एज
एसओसी आपको अगर पता है तो अच्छी बात है,
नहीं भी पता है तो कोई बात नहीं बट पता है
तो अच्छी बात है। एक डीएनएस सेक होती है
टू वैलिडेट डीएनएस रिस्पों्ससेस। डीएनएस
सेक डीएनएस सिक्योरिटी एक तरह की होती है।
एक एक टेक्नोलॉजी है डीएनएस सेक। इसके
बारे में आप थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा।
व्हाट इज़ डीएनएस सेक? ठीक है? आपको थोड़ी
चीजें पता चलेंगी। इसलिए एज अ टास्क आप
रखिए। तो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
उसको यूज़ किया जाता है वैलिडेट करने।
डीएनएस के रिस्पों्ससेस को भी वैलिडेट
करने के लिए कि भैया ये रिस्पांस सही आ
रहा है कि नहीं आ रहा कि ऐसा तो नहीं
मलिशियस रिस्पांस है जैसे अटैकर बार-बार
भेज के डीएनएस को पोइजन कर रहा था। यूज़
सिक्योर एंड ट्रस्टेड डीएनएस रिज़ॉल्वर्स।
डीएनएस रिज़ॉल्वर्स जो वैसे डीएनएस
रिज़ॉल्व्स यूज़ करने चाहिए जो सिक्योर हो,
ट्रस्टेड हो। हमेशा डीएनएस के सॉफ्टवेयर्स
को अपडेट करते रहिए। नेटवर्क मॉनिटरिंग
एंड अलर्टिंग सॉफ्टवेयर्स को यूज़ कीजिए।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है एसओसी एनवायरमेंट में
यूज़ होता ही होता है। फायरवल या आईडीएस को
यूज़ करना चाहिए। एबनॉर्मल डीएनएस ट्रैफिक
अगर बहुत सारा एबनॉर्मल डीएनएस ट्रैफिक
आपको दिख रहा है या एनमलीज़ कोई या कोई
गड़बड़ी दिख रही है तो फायर वाल जो है या
आईडीएस जो है उस चीज को डिटेक्ट कर सकते
हैं। अपने यूज़र्स को एंड अपने एंप्लाइजज़
को यह एडुकेट करना चाहिए कि एक सिक्योर
राउटर कॉन्फ़िगरेशन यूज़ करें। राउटर को
हमेशा सिक्योरली कॉन्फ़िगर रखें। ऐसा नहीं
कि डिफ़ॉल्ट छोड़ दे सबको। राउटर की डिफ़ॉल्ट
सेटिंग्स हमेशा डेंजरस होती है। तो उसको
एक सिक्योर वे में कॉन्फ़िगर करके रखें। अब
एज अ एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट आपके लिए क्विक टिप
क्या हो सकती है? ऑलवेज हमेशा वेरीफाई
आपको करना है कि डोमेन सही IP पे मैप हो
रही है। सोर्स ऑफ़ डीएनएस रिस्पांस क्या
है? डीएनएस रिस्पांस आ कहां से रहा है?
क्या ऑथोरेटिव नेम सर्वर से आ रहा है या
टीएलडी नेम सर्वर से या आपका रूट सर्वर से
आ रहा है या किसी रैंडम आईपी या रैंडम जगह
से आ रहा है? फ्रीक्वेंसी एंड पैटर्न ऑफ़
डीएनएस क्वेरीज़। क्या डीएनएस क्वेरीज़
बार-बार हो रही हैं। ऐसा नहीं कि बहुत
फ्रीक्वेंट हो रही हैं। हो भी रही हैं। तो
किस तरह की डीएनएस क्वेरीज़ हो रही है? ये
सब चेक करना है। कंपेयर विद द थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस मलेशियस आईपी डोमेन लिस्ट। अगर
आपके पास कोई एक ऐसी मलेशियस आईपी या
मलेशियस डोमेनस की लिस्ट है तो उससे हमेशा
जो है आप कंपेयर कीजिए। ठीक है? थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस कहा जाता है। इसको बेसिकली
किसी भी थ्रेट को हावी होने से पहले ही
थ्रेट कोई अटैक करे या थ्रेट कोई किसी तरह
का कोई एक
किसी भी तरह का कोई डैमेज क्रिएट करे।
उसके पहले ही इंटेलिजेंस के थ्रू उसको
डिटेक्ट करना। तो यहां पे एक लिस्ट ऑफ
आईपीस या लिस्ट ऑफ मलेशियस डोमेनस से मैच
करके देखिए भैया कि उनमें से तो ये नहीं
है। राइट? एज सिंपल एज दैट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डीएनएस इज़ द फोन
बुक ऑफ़ द इंटरनेट। इफ द फोनबुक इज़ टपर्ड
यू विल बी रीडायरेक्ट टू द रॉन्ग प्लेस
विदाउट इवन नोइंग। यह बात सही है। डीएनएस
एक फोन बुक होता है इंटरनेट का। सोचिए अगर
आपके फोन बुक में आपके सोचो इसका मैं
सिंपल सा एक एग्जांपल मैं आपको बता देता
हूं कि आप अपने मोबाइल में नंबर सेव करके
रखते हो। आपने नंबर सेव करा है मान लो
पापा नाम से। अब पापा नाम से जो भी आपने
पापा का आपने नंबर सेव किया अब उस
कांटेक्ट में कोई आके एडिट करके वहां पे
आपके पापा के नंबर के जगह पे किसी दूसरे
के नंबर डाल देता है तो आप जब पापा वाले
नंबर पे कॉल करोगे तो वो कहीं और भी फोन
लग जाएगा। आपके पापा के पास तो फोन लगेगा
नहीं। वो कहीं और नंबर लग जाएगा। तो
बेसिकली डीएनएस पोइजनिंग या डीएनएस इसी
तरीके से काम करता है कि सब कुछ सही है तो
बिल्कुल परफेक्ट है आपका। बट जैसे ही वहां
पे पोइजन हुआ कोई और एंट्री आ गई तो आपका
जो कनेक्शन है वो कहीं और भिड़ जाएगा और आप
एक मलिशियस पेज पे चले जाएंगे एंड यू विल
बी रिलेटेड टू अ मलिशियस पेज। ये बात समझ
में आ गई सबको एग्जांपल के थ्रू और क्लियर
हो गया? सभी लोग बताइए मुझे एवरीवन लेट मी
नो गाइस आर यू आर यू क्लियर अबाउट इट?
बताइए।
एवरीवन प्लीज रेसोंड एंड लाइक ठोकते जाओ
भाई। 100 लाइक्स भी नहीं हुए? बड़े शर्म की
बात है। सभी लोग बताइए।
परफेक्ट क्या बात है।
हम [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] चलिए अब
आते हैं डीएनएस पोइजनिंग का रियल अटैक
फ्लो पे। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सो रियल अटैक फ्लो क्या होता है? रियल जो
आपका अटैक फ्लो है वो क्या होता है? पहले
में अटैकर डीएनएस को पोइजन करता है। यूजर
जैसे bank.com टाइप करता है तो डीएनएस जो
है वह एक अटैकर की आईपी को लाके देता है
क्योंकि वो एक फेक
कैश एक बेसिकली पोइजन कैश रिज़ॉल्वर कैश से
आईपी निकाल के देता है। फिर फेक लॉगिन पेज
आती है। वहां आप डिटेल्स डालते हैं और
आपका डिटेल चुरा लिया जाता है। ये हालांकि
मैंने इमेज के थ्रू भी बता दिया था। बट ये
वापस से एक बार रिवाइज हो गया। अब एसओसी
इंडिकेटर मैंने आपको पहले भी बता चुका बता
चुका हूं। मैं इमेज के थ्रू एसोस इंडिकेटर
बट एक बार रिपीट थोड़े से पॉइंट डीएनएस
रेज़ोल्यूशन मिसमैच डीएनएस का जो
रेज़ोल्यूशन होगा यानी आईपी से डो डोमेन से
आईपी वाला वो गड़बड़ होगी डीएनएस में सडन
चेंज होगा सर्टिफिकेट वार्निंग आएंगी
मल्टीपल यूज़र्स जो है उनको इंपैक्ट करेंगे
एक साथ तो इस तरह की चीजें ये एसओसी
इंडिकेटर के तौर पे आता है। ये मैंने
ऑलरेडी डिस्कस कर लिया है। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे रियल
एसोसिएट सिनेरियो की अगर बात करें तो यूजर
कंप्लेन क्या कर सकते हैं कि भैया Google
जो है थोड़ा डिफरेंट दिख रहा है या यह
वेबसाइट जो है थोड़ी डिफरेंट दिख रही है।
डीएनएस लॉग्स में आपका Google अननोन आईपी
पे आपका जो है वो रिज़ॉल्व हो रहा होगा।
Google की जो रियल आईपी होगी उस पे
रिज़ॉल्व ना होके किसी अननोन आईपी पे
रिज़ॉल्व हो रहा होगा। तो ये एक एसओसी
सिनेरियो है जहां पे आपको अगर ऐसे लॉग्स
मिल रहे हैं, ऐसी कंप्लेंट्स मिल रही है
तो उस पे आपको एक्टिव रहना है। आपको उस पे
जो भी आपको कदम उठाने हैं, जो भी आपको
स्टेप्स लेने हैं वो लेने हैं एज एसओसीएल
वन। तो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कंक्लूजन क्या है? है डीएनए पोइजनिंग अटैक
आपके हो रहा है। तो अगर मैं बात करूं
डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग और डीएनएस पोइजनिंग
के बीच के डिफरेंस की तो यहां पे बहुत
सिंपल सा डिफरेंस है। अगर हम
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
स्टेज [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] की बात
करें तो फुटप्रिंटिंग एक रेकॉन का स्टेज
होता है। आपके अटैकिंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो अटैकिंग जो
पूरी प्रोसेस होती है उसमें रेकॉन का स्टे
स्टेज होता है। पोइजनिंग एक अटैक वाला फेज
होता है। गोल गोल में अगर बात करें तो
इसमें फुटप्रिंटिंग में इनेशन गैदर किया
जाता है। पोइजनिंग में रीडायरेक्ट किया
जाता है मलेशियस अह लोकेशनेशंस पे।
विजिबिलिटी की बात करें तो फुटप्रिंटिंग
एक लो विजिबिलिटी अटैक मतलब अटैक या
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग प्रोसेस है जिसमें कि
अटैकर का विजिबिलिटी लो होता है थोड़ा कम
होता है वो कम डिटेक्ट होता है और यहां पे
इसकी मीडियम डिटेक्शन होती है। इंपैक्ट की
बात करें तो फुटप्रिंटिंग जो है एक प्लंड
एक अप्रोच होता है जिसमें प्लानिंग मतलब
प्लानिंग वाली इंपैक्ट होती है एक तरह से
बहुत ज्यादा इंपैक्ट नहीं होगा। बट
कॉम्प्रोमाइज पोइजनिंग वाली में पूरा का
पूरा सिस्टम कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाएगा। एंड
बड़ बहुत बढ़िया वाला अटै जो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इंपैक्ट है वो होगा। अब एज अ सोशल
एनालिस्ट
एसओसी एनालिस्ट सोशल एनालिस्ट नहीं एसओसी
एनालिस्ट माइंडसेट की अगर बात करें तो जब
भी आप डीएनएस लॉग्स को देखते हैं जब भी आप
डीएनएस के लॉग्स को चेक करें डीएनएस के
लॉग्स को देखें तो आपको सिर्फ ये नहीं
पूछना है कि व्हाट डोमेन इज़ दिस? आपको ये
नहीं पूछना है कि व्हाट इज़ व्हाट इज़ दिस
डोमेन? क्या है ये डोमेन? ऐसा नहीं। आपको
पूछना है व्हाई इज़ दिस डोमेन बीइंग
क्वीरड? ये डोमेन क्यों क्वेरी की जा रही
है? इज़ द पैटर्न नॉर्मल? क्या यह क्वेरी
पैटर्न नॉर्मल है? इज़ द रिस्पांस करेक्ट?
क्या यह रिस्पांस करेक्ट है? यह आपको अपने
आप से क्वेश्चन करने हैं। बीइंग एन एसओसी
एल1 बीइंग एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट बंग एन
जूनियर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट। ये आपको अपने
आप से क्वेरी करनी है। ठीक है? ये एक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एसओसी का
माइंडसेट है आपका। ये आपका
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग था। डीएनएस पोइजनिंग आई थिंक
क्लियर हो गया होगा सभी का।
ओके? 93 [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लाइक्स
हो चुके हैं। 100 भी हो जाएंगे मुझे पता
है। थैंक यू वेरी मच। एंड डीएनएस पोइजनिंग
आई थिंक क्लियर हो गया होगा। अब हमारे पास
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो टॉपिक है वो
है एपीटी। यह छोटा सा टॉपिक है। इसको हम
डील कर लेते हैं। सो दैट इट गेट
कंप्लीटेड। एपीटी एडवांस्ड पर्सिस्टेंट
थ्रेट। यहां पे इसका मतलब होता है एपीटी।
ठीक है? अब एपीटी जो है अपने आप में एक
बहुत ब्रॉड बहुत ही ह्यूज एंड बहुत ही
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक है। याद रखिएगा। ये तो
मैंने अभी मैं जो बताऊंगा ये आपको एसओसी
के पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से छोटा सा एक बेसिक
एपीटी के बारे में बताऊंगा। बट एपीटी अपने
आप में एक बहुत ही एडवांस टॉपिक है। एपीटी
के अंदर में दुनिया की अ सारे सारी चीजें
हैं हैकिंग की। देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स
दैट यू कुड गो थ्रू इनसाइड एपीटी। काफी
चीजें आपको इसके अंदर सीखनी पड़ती है
एपीटी के अंदर में। तो आज मैं एपीटी का
पूरा कांसेप्ट क्लियर कर दूंगा। एपीटी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आपको अच्छे से
समझा दूंगा कि एपीटी एग्जैक्टली होती क्या
है? सो दैट आप कभी फ्यूचर में इसको डिटेल
इन डेप्थ पढ़ने की कोशिश करें तो आपको समझ
में एक्चुअली आ जाए। राइट?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंट थ्रेट अ टारगेटेड
लॉन्ग टर्म साइबर अटैक वेयर अटैकर्स गेन
एक्सेस एंड स्टे हिडन इनसाइड अ नेटवर्क
फॉर अ लॉन्ग टाइम। एपीटी का मतलब यही होता
है कि एक एडवांस अटैक जिसके बाद
पर्सिस्टेंस लेता है अटैकर थ्रेट
क्रिएट करके अटैक्स ल्च करता है। इसका
मतलब है एक ऐसा लॉन्ग टर्म साइबर अटैक
जिसमें अटैकर जब किसी नेटवर्क के अंदर
किसी सर्वर के अंदर किसी कंप्यूटर को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लेता है या सर्वर को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लेता है। नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लेता
है तो वो वहीं पे रुकता नहीं है। ना ही वह
अपनी ट्रेस छोड़ेगा। ना ही वो अपने आपको
दिखाएगा कि मैंने इस चीज को कॉम्प्रोमाइज
कर लिया है। वो चुपचाप वहीं पे बैठा
रहेगा। बहुत लंबे टाइम के लिए कई बार 1
महीने कई बार छ महीने कई बार एक साल कई
बार 2 साल 5 साल ऐसे वो बैठा रहेगा जब तक
पकड़ा ना जाए ऑब्वियस सी बात है कि कई बार
कई केसेस में होते हैं कि कितने महीने तक
हटाकर एक नेटवर्क के अंदर में
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके उसको उसके अंदर चुपचाप
बैठा रहता है। वो क्यों बैठा रहता है?
उसका उसका मोटिव क्या होता है? उसका मोटिव
है कि बहुत ही डीपर लेवल ऑफ इंपैक्ट
क्रिएट करना उस अटैक को लेके एंड ज्यादा
से ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन को रिट्रीव करना
ज्यादा से ज्यादा ऐसी डिटेल्स को निकालना
जो यूजुअली बहुत सेंसिटिव हो सकते हैं या
यूजुअली कंपनी के लिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट हो
सकती है। एंड वैसे इंफॉर्मेशन को निकालना,
चुराना या एक्सफिल्ट्रेट करना। ठीक है?
एक्स फिल्ट्रेट का मतलब है उसको निकालना।
यह काम होता है। सो डेटा की सारी
हार्वेस्टिंग है। ये डेटा हार्वेस्टिंग
अटैक है। एक तरह से डेटा हार्वेस्टिंग की
जाती है। डेटा को चुराया जाता है। तो यहां
पे मैं तीनों टर्म को अगर अलग-अलग बताऊं
एडवांस का मतलब है सोफिस्टिकेटेड
टेक्निक्स का यूज़ करना। मैं एडवांस,
पर्सिस्टेंट एंड थ्रेट। तीनों का मतलब
समझा देता हूं यहां पे इस एपीटी में।
सोफिस्टिकेटेड टेक्निक्स को यूज़ करना। ठीक
है? कस्टम मैलवेयर जीरो डेज और इवेशंस का
यूज करना मतलब कस्टम मैलवेयर्स को यूज
करना जो जनरली बहुत ज्यादा इंपैक्टफुल
होते हैं। जीरो डेज वनेबिलिटी को यूज़ करना
जिसका कोई भी अभी तक पैच नहीं निकला है।
जिसका कोई सॉल्यूशन नहीं है। ऐसी
वनेबिलिटी जिनको एक्सप्लइट किया जा रहा
है। बट उसका कोई भी पैच नहीं है। उसको ठीक
नहीं किया गया है। वह अभी भी एक्सप्लइटेबल
है और उसके थ्रू किसी भी सिस्टम को किसी
भी लेटेस्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को हैक किया
जा सकता है या सर्वर को हैक किया जा सकता
है। वैसे वलेबिलिटीज को यूज़ करना और इवेशन
किसी भी एंटीवायरस को बाईपास करने की
कोशिश करना, बड़े से बड़े एंटीवायरसेस को
बाईपास करने की कोशिश करना। यह सारी चीजें
किया जाता है। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड एडवांस्ड। ये
एडवांस के अंदर में आ गया। अब आते हैं
पर्सिस्टेंट। पर्सिस्टेंट में क्या हो
जाता है? स्टेज़ इन द सिस्टम फॉर वीक्स,
मंथ्स या इयर्स। मैंने जैसे कि बताया कि
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एक सिस्टम के
अंदर में कई दिनों तक रहना, कई महीनों तक
रहना, कई केसेस में कई सालों तक रह जाना,
मेंटेन एक्सेस इवन आफ्टर डिटेक्शन
अटेमप्ट्स। डिटेक्शन के अटेम्प्ट्स भी हो
रहे हैं उस नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी जो टीम है या उनकी
सिक्योरिटी टीम है। कई बार कोशिश भी कर
रही है डिटेक्ट करने की। स्टिल उसके बाद
भी एक्सेस को मेंटेन करना, एक्सेस बनाए
रखना और उसी के अंदर में चुपचाप आराम से
बैठे रहना। थ्रेट ऑर्गेनाइज़्ड अटैक ऑफ़ एेन
नेशन स्टेट और स्किल्ड ग्रुप्स एंड यह एक
ऑर्गेनाइज़्ड अटैक करना एक ऑर्गेनाइज़्ड
थ्रेट का मतलब होता है एक ऑर्गेनाइज़्ड
अटैक बड़े लेवल का अटैक एक बड़े लेवल का चेन
अटैक यू कैन से बेसिकली एक नेशन या एक
स्टेट स्पों्सर्ड हैकर्स होते हैं या जो
स्किल्ड ग्रुप्स हैकर ग्रुप्स होते हैं।
इस तरह के जो ग्रुप्स होते हैं या लार्ज
हैकर ग्रुप्स जो होते हैं वो इस तरह के
अटैक्स को ल्च करते हैं। यहां पे सबसे
बड़ी चीज होती है इस चीज के लिए बहुत ही
ज्यादा
एक क्यूरेटेड टूल्स की रिक्वायरमेंट होती
है। इसमें ऐसे रैट्स का यूज़ किया जाता है
जो कि मलिशियस हो, हिडन हो,
क्रिप्टोग्राफिकली बहुत स्ट्रांग हो,
जिनको बायपास जिनको डिटेक्ट ना किया जाए
एंटीवायरसेस के तरफ से जो इवेशंस के लिए
यूज़ में लिए जाते हो, ज़ीरो डज़ एक्सप्लइट्स
करके उसको यूज़ में लिए जाते हो, कस्टम
मैल्वस का यूज़ किया गया हो इनफेक्ट करने
के लिए या कस्टम रैट्स का यूज़ किया गया।
रिमोट एक्सेस ट्रोजंस को तो ये सारी चीजें
यूज़ में ली जाती है। ठीक है? थैंक यू
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] टेक्नो स्पार्क
तो ये तीन चीजें एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंट
थ्रेट। अब कैसे ये वर्क करता है? तो अटैकर
जो है मालवेयर इंट्रोड्यूस करता है।
एक्सेस गेन कर लेता है। एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव
राइट्स ले लेता है सिस्टम या नेटवर्क की।
उसके बाद डीपर डिग करता है। पूरे नेटवर्क
में डीपर घुसता है। एंड उसी में छुपा हुआ
रहता है। चुपचाप हिडन रहता है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
अच्छी बात है गौरव
गुड [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यह हिडन
रहता है। अब यहां पे हम समझते हैं इसकी
पूरी अटैक चेन को एपीटी अटैक का पूरा जो
अटैक चेन है उसको समझते हैं। लेट्स सी इफ
मैग्नीिफायर इज़ वर्किंग ऑ नॉट इस पे।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आई होप मैग्नीिफायर आपका यहां पर काम कर
रहा है। इसको साइड कर देता हूं। आपको
क्लियर दिख रही है क्या? मैग्नीिफायर के
थ्रू ब्लरनेस तो नहीं आ रही है? एक बार
मुझे बता दीजिए। इफ मैग्नीिफायर से आपको
क्लियर दिख रही है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] टेक्स्ट वगैरह
और जो भी चीजें आपको क्लियर दिख रही है?
मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मैंने यहां पर
जूम किया हुआ है।
मैंने अभी जूम किया है बट ये ज़ूम दिख नहीं
रहा है। आई थिंक आपको
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्योंकि जिस तरह की चीजें हैं आई थिंक
मुझे ये सब भी दिख रहा है। आई डोंट थिंक
सो कि zूम इज वर्किंग हियर। चलो आप अपने
स्क्रीन पर जूम कर लेना। आप अपने स्क्रीन
पर जूम कर लेना। बट आपको दिख रहा है क्या?
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां। दिख रहा है ना?
ओके।
ओके। नहीं दिख रहा आपको?
चलो मैं एक बार ट्राई करता हूं इसको
डाउनलोड यह हो जाएगी क्या?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
मैं यहां कॉपी करता हूं।
एंड
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लेट्स सी इफ इट इज़
कमिंग हियर
एंड इफ वी कैन ज़ूम इन दिस थिंग।
यहां मैं दिखाता हूं आपको। शायद यहां ज़ूम
करके आपको ज्यादा क्लियर दिख रहा है।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब मुझे बताइए कि नाउ इज इट विज़िबल? अब
आपको ज्यादा क्लियर दिख रहा है क्या? यहां
पे मैं वर्ड में मैंने पेस्ट करके इसको
आपको आपको मैं दिखा रहा हूं। तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब ज्यादा क्लियर है क्या?
मुझे एक बार कंफर्म कर दीजिए सभी लोग।
इज इट मोर क्लियर? लेट मी नो फर्स्ट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
पूरी क्लियर है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक है। थैंक
यू। चलो बहुत अच्छी बात है। मैंने वहां से
इससे उठा के यहां पे ला दिया ताकि यहां पे
शायद उतनी क्लियर आपको नहीं दिख रही थी।
सो यहां मैंने आपके लिए लाया यह चीज। ठीक
है?
ये क्या है? हाइलाइटर है क्या?
इस पे काम नहीं करता हलाइटर।
ओके। ठीक है। कोई बात नहीं। चलिए अब यहां
पे अ लेट्स स्टार्ट। यहां पर समझते हैं
फुल अटैक चेन ऑफ एन एपीटी अटैक। एपीटी
अटैक का फुल अटैक चेन जो है उसको थोड़ा सा
समझते हैं कि पूरा का पूरा अटैक चेन आपका
क्या होता है। देखो एपीटी मैं यहां पे
कर्सर जो है मैं यहां कर्सर के थ्रू आपको
बता रहा हूं यहां पे। आई होप कि आप कर्सर
को सम देख पा रहे होंगे।
इस पे कोई अगर एक वो हो जाता तो अच्छा
होता। बट यह मेरे कर्सर पे कुछ आ नहीं पा
रहा है।
सो
नहीं आ रहा है इमेज के ऊपर शायद नहीं होती
होगी। ठीक है कोई बात नहीं। चलो इसी पर हम
देख लेते हैं। यह कर्सर के ऊपर आप देख
लेना। अ
ठीक है।
हम हम हम [हंसी]
ठीक है। चलिए देखते हैं यहां पे। पेंट
पेंट में करें क्या?
चलो पेंट में एक बार पेस्ट करके देखते
हैं।
इफ इट्स वर्किंग हियर यहां तो कुछ
यहां तो कुछ आ ही नहीं रहा है यार।
कॉपी
इवन यहां पेस्ट का ऑप्शन भी नहीं आ रहा।
पेंट में तो खैर शायद नहीं हो पाएगा। सो
लीव इट। यहीं पे कर लेते हैं। चलो ठीक है।
इट्स गुड।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
फुल अटैक चेन अगर हम देखें एपीटी अटैक की
फुल अटैक अ फुल अटैक तो देखो पहला आपका जो
होता है वो रिकॉनसेंस होता है जो एडवांस
पर्सिस्टेंस सेट होती है उसमें पहला जो
होता है रिकिसेंस है आपका दूसरा आपका
वेपनाइजेशन होता है तीसरा डिलीवरी होती है
चौथा इनिशियल एक्सेस होता है पांचवा
एग्जीक्यूशन होता है छठा आपका पर्सिस्टेंस
होता है सातवां आपका प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
होता है आठवां क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस होता है
नौवां डिस्कवरी होती है। 10वां लेटरल
मूवमेंट होता है। 11वां कमांड एंड कंट्रोल
होता है। 12 जो होता है एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन
एंड इंपैक्ट होता है। ये 12 जो है आपके जो
है पूरे स्टेप्स होते हैं। इसमें आपको
साइबर किल चेन के कुछ स्टेप्स आपको यहां
पे दिख रहे होंगे। कुछ फैमिलियर नेम्स दिख
रहे होंगे। ये पूरा का पूरा एपीटी अटैक
लाइफ लाइफ साइकिल होता है या अटैक चेन
होता है जिसके थ्रू ये अटैक किए जाते हैं।
एक अटैकर इसके थ्रू ये अटैक करता है। अब
देखो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इसमें
होता क्या है? एपीटी एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंट
थ्रेट अटैक्स आर टारगेटेड लॉन्ग टर्म एंड
मल्टीस्टेज अटैक्स वेयर अटैकर गेन इनिशियल
एक्सेस पर्सिस्ट इनसाइड द नेटवर्क एंड
एक्सफिल्ट्रेट डेटा क्या करते हैं ये एक
टारगेटेड लॉन्ग टर्म एंड बहुत मल्टीपल
स्टेजेस में होने वाले अटैक हैं जहां
अटैकर पहले इनिशियली एक्सेस को गेन करता
है देन उसी नेटवर्क के अंदर में
पर्सिस्टेंस एग्जीक्यूट होता है अपने आप
को पर्सिस्टेंस बनाता है यानी कि उसमें
हमेशा रह जाए इवन डिटेक्शन के बाद भी वह
ना हटे एंड उसी नेटवर्क में बैठा रहे अटैक
उसका जो है एग्जीक्यूट होता रहे एंड ऑटो
उसका जो कंट्रोल है हमेशा बना रहे एंड
डेटा को एक्सिल्ट्रेट करता है डेटा को
आपके चुराता है या डेटा जो भी निकालता है
वो निकालता है तो पहला रिकॉनसेंस स्टेप है
इसके बारे में सब लोगों को पता है कि
इनेशन गैदरिंग होती है बेसिकली जैसे अटैकर
रिसर्चेस द टारगेट गैदर्स इनेशन अबाउट
डोमेन एंप्लाइजज़ टेक्नोलॉजी पार्टनर्स
सोशल मीडिया ईटीसी जो भी अटैकर के बारे
में जो भी टारगेट के बारे में जितनी
डिटेल्स निकल सकती है। वो सब डिटेल्स
रिक्निसेंस के थ्रू निकालता है। उसके बाद
होती है वेपनाइजेशन। वेपनाइजेशन में अटैकर
क्रिएट्स मलशियस पेलोड्स और यूज़ द
एक्सप्लइट। पेलोड इज़ क्राफ्टेड टू बायपास
सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स। अब अटैकर क्या करता
है कि मलेशियस पेलोड्स यहां पे बनाता है
आपका और एक्सप्लइट्स को यूज़ करता है। यहां
जीरो डे एक्सप्लइट्स को भी यूज़ किया जा
सकता है। एंड उसके थ्रू क्या करता है? बाय
सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स को बाईपास करता है।
यह सेकंड स्टेप में करता है। उसके बाद आती
है डिलीवरी। डिलीवरी में यहां पे मलेशियस
पेलोड इज डिलीवर टू द विक्टिम। मलेशियस
पेलोड विक्टिम को डिलीवर किया जाता है एंड
ट्रिक्स द यूजर इंटू एग्जीक्यूटिंग। और
उसको ट्रिक किया जाता है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
या वेरियस अदर टेक्निक्स के थ्रू कि उसको
वो एग्जीक्यूट करे। जैसे एग्जीक्यूट हुआ
अब इनिशियल एक्सेस आता है। पेलोड इज़
एग्जीक्यूटेड ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम। अटैकर
गेंस अ फुटहोल्ड इन द एनवायरमेंट। अब
अटैकर जो है उसके अंदर एक पहला
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कदम पहला जो
अपना कदम है पहला अपना धुरंधर कदम रखता है
और उसके अंदर एंट्री लेता है जैसे धुरंधर
वाली एंट्री थी। ठीक है? वैसी एंट्री।
उसके बाद होती है एग्जीक्यूशन। अब मलशियस
कोड्स रन ऑन द सिस्टम कैन लॉन्च एक
स्क्रिप्ट्स, मैवेयर्स और टूल्स। अब क्या
होते हैं? मशियस कोड्स जो हैं वो रन होते
हैं। क्या होते हैं? मलेशियस कोड्स को रन
किए जाते हैं। एंड इस केस में मलेशियस कोड
जब रन होते हैं तो क्या होता है कि अब
स्क्रिप्ट्स को ल्च किया जा सकता है।
मेलवेज़ को ल्च किया जा सकता है। अलग-अलग
टूल्स को ल्च किया जा सकता है। ये सारी
चीजें होती हैं। देन आती है पर्सिस्टेंस।
अटैकर इस्टैब्लिशज़ पर्सिस्टेंस टू मेंटेन
एक्सेस इवन आफ्टर रिबूूट्स। कि अब अटैकर
अपनी पर्सिस्टेंस वहां पे मेंटेन करता है
कि अगर सिस्टम रिबूूट भी हो जाए या कोई
अगर अटैक को डिटेक्ट भी करने की कोशिश की
जाए उसको हटाने की भी कोशिश की जाए फिर भी
वो अटैक चलता रहे एंड वो जो एग्जीक्यूशन
है वो अपनी बनी रहे। देन आती है प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन। उसके बाद क्या होता है? अटैकर
एस्केलेट्स प्रिविलेजेस टू गेन हायर
एक्सेस। अब अटैकर मान लो अगर एक नॉर्मल
एक्सेस करके रखता है। नॉर्मल एक अ
इंटरेक्शन हुई रहती है या नॉर्मल एक्सेस
होता है। नॉर्मल यूजर की तरह वो रहता है
तो उसको एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर या रूट यूजर
की तरह बनने की कोशिश करता है। अपनी
प्रिविलेज को इंक्रीस करता है। अपनी
प्रिविलेज को बढ़ाता है।
अटैकर स्टील्स और हार्वेस्ट्स
क्रेडेंशियल्स फ्रॉम मेमोरी और सिस्टम्स।
देन क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस आती है। जहां पे
अटैकर क्या करता है? क्रेडेंशियल्स को
हार्वेस्ट करता है या मेमोरी से या सिस्टम
से चुराता है। अपने क्रेडेंशियल्स को
चुराता है। ठीक है? उसमें अलग-अलग टूल्स
यहां पे आपको एग्जांपल्स में दिख रहे
होंगे। जैसे मिड, जेल्स डैंप ये सब को यूज़
करता है। अब ये सब चीज़ अगर आपने थ्योरी
क्लासेस पहले की नहीं देखी होंगी तो आपको
नहीं समझ में आएगा। ऑब्वियस सी बात है।
जिन्होंने देखी होगी उनको पता होगा। तभी
तो मैं बोलता हूं थ्यरीज़ आर वेरीेंट। एंड
हर क्लास को बहुत बारीकी से और बहुत ही
माइनटली, बहुत आराम से, ईजीली डिटेल में
देखोगे तो आपको सब चीज़ समझ में आ जाएगी।
बहुत मजा आएगा आपको। तो उसके बाद आठवां
स्टेप आएगा क्रेडेंशियल्स एक्सेस का।
क्रेडेंशियल को एक्सेस करता है, हार्वेस्ट
करता है। देन आती है डिस्कवरी की। अटैकर
एक्सप्लोरस द नेटवर्क टू फाइंड एसेट्स,
यूजर्स, शेयर्स एंडेंट डेटा। अब जब वो
क्रेडेंशियल्स एक्सेस कर चुका है, अपनी
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेट कर चुका है। तो अब वो
नेटवर्क के अंदर घूमने लगता है, भटकने
लगता है कि भैया कहां-कहां पे कुछ एसेट्स
हैं, ऐसे इंटरेस्टिंग यूज़र्स हैं,
इंटरेस्टिंग शेयर्स हैं, शेयरर्ड फोल्डर्स
हैं, डेटाज़ हैं, फाइल्स हैं, इंपॉर्टेंट
डेटा हैं। उन सबको खोजना शुरू कर देता है।
देन लैटरल मूवमेंट होती है। अटैकर मूव्स
टू अदर सिस्टम्स इन द नेटवर्क यूजिंग
वैलिड क्रेडेंशियल्स और एक्सप्लइट्स।
फर्दर एक्सप्लइट्स को यूज़ करता है या
फर्दर क्रेडेंशियल्स को यूज करके अब वो
अंदर ही अंदर नेटवर्क के अंदर में एक
सिस्टम से दूसरे सिस्टम में घूमने लगता है
जिसको लेटरल मूवमेंट बोलते हैं। आप सबको
मैंने पहले ही बताया हुआ है। तो ये काम
होने लगती है। उसके बाद आती है कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल। C2 कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम्स
कम्युनिकेट्स विद द अटैकर्स C2 सर्वर फॉर
कमांड्स। अब जितने भी सिस्टम्स को उसने
कॉम्प्रोमाइज किए हैं या उसने
कॉम्प्रोमाइज किए हैं उन सारे
कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम की कम्युनिकेशन होती
है C2 सर्वर से। जो अटैकर का खुद का कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर होता है उससे उसकी
कम्युनिकेशन होती है और वहीं कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल सर्वर से सारे कमांड्स या सारे
इंस्ट्रक्शंस आते हैं। जैसे कि धुरंधर में
हमारे भाई इंडियन स्पाई जो हमारे थे उनको
ऊपर से ऑर्डर आ रहे थे इंडिया में
बैठे-बैठे रॉ के हेड क्वार्टर से। राइट?
तो वो इसी तरीके से आपका सी टू सर्वर जो
है वो कमांड्स भेजता है और उसी के
अकॉर्डिंग वो सिस्टम्स ऑपरेट करते हैं।
देन आती है एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन एंड इंपैक्ट।
अटैकर्स स्टील्स डाटा एंड एक्सफिल्ट्रेट
इट मे डिसररप्ट इंक्रिप्ट और डिस्ट्रॉय
सिस्टम। अटैकर क्या करता है? डाटा को
चुराता है। उसको निकालता है बाहर अपने C2
सर्वर के थ्रू अपने सिस्टम अपने पास लेकर
आता है। उसके बाद हो सकता है वो पूरी
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को डिसररप्ट कर
दे या इंक्रिप्ट कर दे। रैंसमवेयर टाइप का
कुछ कर रसमवेयर अटैक उसमें ल्च कर दे। फिर
रैंसमवेयर की पॉप अप ला दे कि भ इतना पैसे
दो। हमारे पास सारा डाटा है। हम डाटा हम
आपको रिटाइव करके हम आपको सारा डाटा वापस
कर देंगे या इंक्रिप्टेड डेटा को
डिक्रिप्ट कर देंगे। एंड या तो सिस्टम की
ही बैंड बजा देगा। ठीक है? तो बेसिकली
रैंसमवेयर या वाइपर का यूज़ किया जाता है
यहां पे डिटक्च फिल्ट्रेशन वगैरह करने के
बाद। ये पूरा का पूरा अटैक साइकिल है। ये
अटैक साइकिल आई थिंक आपको समझ में आ गई
होगी। राइट? बहुत बहुत इजी वे में मैंने
समझाने के लिए ये चीज आपके सामने लेकर आया
था ताकि आपको अच्छे से समझ में आ जाए कि
ये पूरी की पूरी एपीटी की लाइफ साइकिल जो
एपीटी का आपका पूरा अटैक चेन होता है वो
कैसे काम करता है। अब इसी में हम बात करते
हैं एपीटी के एपीटी के थ्रू अटैकर्स का
गोल क्या होता है? तो सेंसिटिव डेटा को
चुराना होता है। स्पायोनेज या इंटेलिजेंस
स्पायोनेज या इंटेलिजेंस के थ्रू मतलब
डेटा को निकालना जानकारी या सेंसिटिव
जानकारियां चुराना होता है। फाइनेंशियल
गेन के लिए होता है या डिसररप्शन या किसी
की बिनेस को डिसरप्ट करना, कंपनी को
डिरप्ट करना, नेटवर्क को डिसरप्ट
करना ये सारी चीजें आपकी होती है। एसओसी
के लिए कॉमन इंडिकेटर्स क्या हो सकते हैं
भैया? अगर कॉमन इंडिकेटर्स की बात करें
एसओसी व्यू के लिए तो अनयूजुअल आउटबाउंड
कनेक्शंस बाहर के बाहर के नेटवर्क के साथ
कुछ ज्यादा ही अनयूजुअल कनेक्ट कनेक्शन बन
रहा है आपके सिस्टम्स की मतलब समझ जाइए वो
सीएनसी सर्वर हो सकता है सी टू सर्वर
अननोन डोमेन आईपी का प्रेजेंस होना
मल्टीपल सिस्टम्स एक्सेस करना मल्टीपल
सिस्टम्स का एक्सेस हुआ है पावर शेल या
wmआई जो होती है उसका अब्यूज करना पावर
शेल के थ्रू अब्यूज हो रहा है पावर शेल का
यू अब यूज़ हो रहा है मल्टीपल आर्बिटरी
कमांड्स डाले जा रहे क्रेडेंशियल्स डंपिंग
एक्टिविटी। क्रेडेंशियल्स को डंप करने की
एक्टिविटी कुछ हो जा रही है। लैटरल
मूवमेंट्स डिटेक्ट हो रहे हैं। अनयुअल
लॉगिन्स हो रहे हैं। अनयूजुअल टाइम्स पे
बहुत बड़े-बड़े डेटा की ट्रांसफर्स हो रही
है। सिक्योरिटी टूल्स को डिसेबल किया जा
रहा है। एंड पर्सिस्टेंस टाइप की चीज आपको
फील हो रहा है, एहसास हो रहा है। अगर ऐसा
कुछ इंडिकेटर आपको मिल रहा है, समझिए कि
वहां पे एपीटी लेवल के अटैक होने की
पॉसिबिलिटीज़ हैं। अब इसमें डिफेंस की सबसे
अच्छी प्रैक्टिस क्या होती है कि आप अपने
सॉफ्टवेयर्स को सिस्टम्स को हमेशा अपडेट
रखिए। स्ट्रांग ईमेल फिल्टरिंग रूल्स को
यूज कीजिए। मॉनिटर कीजिए। जितने भी लॉग्स
हैं आपके नेटवर्क के लॉग्स, ट्रैफिक के
लॉग्स होते हैं, उस सबको मॉनिटर कीजिए।
उसको एग्जामिन कीजिए अच्छे से। बीइंग एन
एसओसी ईडीआर या एक्सडीआर सॉल्यूशन को यूज़
कीजिए। ईडीआर एक एसडीआर के बारे में हम
जानेंगे। आने वाले एडवांस टॉपिक्स जब आपके
एसओसी के होंगे तो हम ईडीआर एक्सडीआर के
बारे में भी पढ़ेंगे। एमआईटीआर मित्र
फ्रेमवर्क के बारे में पढ़ेंगे।
प्रैक्टिकल्स भी करेंगे। सब कुछ करेंगे।
तो ये एक्स सॉलशंस को इंप्लीमेंट करना
चाहिए। इनफोर्स लिस्ट प्रिविलेज एक्सेस
मतलब कि जितना कम एक्सेस वाला चीज हम
इनफोर्स कर सके सिस्टम्स के अंदर में वही
रखना चाहिए। बहुत हाई एक्सेस रूट यूजर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव यूजर को हर जगह बैठा के
नहीं रखना है। हर जगह ओपन नहीं रखना है।
ठीक है? सेगमेंटेशन आपको करके रखनी चाहिए।
नेटवर्क्स को सेगमेंट्स में डिवाइड करिए।
ऐसा नहीं कि आप एक नेटवर्क में अंदर घुस
के और वो मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस तक पहुंच जाए।
मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस को एक पेनिट्रेट कर दे।
ऐसा भी नहीं होना चाहिए। सिक्योरिटी
अवेयरनेस की ट्रेनिंग्स देते रहिए
एंप्लाइजज़ को। क्योंकि कई बार नहीं
बार-बार मैक्सिमम टाइम एंप्लाइजज़ के थ्रू
ही ऐसे अटैक्स ल्च किए जाते हैं।
एंप्लाइजज़ को पागल बनाया जाता है।
एंप्लाइजज़ [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] के
ऊपर हनी ट्रैप किया जाता है। सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग की जाती है। उससे डाटा निकाला
जाता है। उससे डाटा चुराया जाता है। उससे
डाटा निकलवाया जाता है। तब जाके ऐसे
अटैक्स जो है ईज़ली एग्जीक्यूट कर दिए जाते
हैं। एंड उसके बाद एक अपना खुद का
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस प्लान होना चाहिए कि
कोई अगर ऐसी बड़ी कोई इंसिडेंट होती है।
कोई बड़ा अटैक होता है तो उस केस में कैसे
हम उसको रिस्पॉन्ड करें। किस तरीके से
क्या-क्या हम मेजर्स वहां पे लें? किस
तरीके से हम रिस्पांस हमें देना चाहिए।
बीइंग एन एसोसिए एनालिस्ट, बीइंग एन अ
डिफेंस मैकेनिज्म। अगर हम एक फर्स्ट लाइन
ऑफ़ डिफेंस है तो हमें किस तरीके से उनको
सेफगार्ड करना चाहिए? सिंपल सा फंडा है।
ठीक है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए, एपीटी अटैक्स आर स्टिल्थी।
ठीक है? पेशेंट एंड स्ट्रेटेजिक। बहुत ही
स्टिल्थ होते हैं। जल्दी दिखते नहीं है।
जल्दी पता नहीं चलता है। दे ब्लेंड वि द
नॉर्मल एक्टिविटी टू अवॉयड डिटेक्शन।
नॉर्मल जो डे टू डे लाइफ एक्टिविटीज होती
हैं उसके साथ वो मिल जाते हैं। उसके साथ
वो ब्लेंड कर जाते हैं। अर्ली डिटेक्शन
एंड मॉनिटरिंग बहुत मुश्किल होती है कि
शुरुआत में ही डिटेक्ट हो जाए। बाद में
होती है जब तक बहुत दिक्कतें बहुत सारी
चीजें डैमेज हो चुकी होती हैं। प्रिवेंशन
प्लस रिस्पांस इज़ इक्वल टू रिड्यूस्ड
इंपैक्ट। यानी कि अगर आप अच्छे से
प्रिवेंशन रखें, अच्छे से रिस्पांस करें
इसके लिए तो एक अच्छा इंपैक्ट जो है
क्रिएट करता है। आपके जो इसका एपीटी का
अटैक का इंपैक्ट है वो कहीं ना कहीं कम हो
जाता है। तो ये पूरा का पूरा अटैक चेन है
आपके एपीटी अटैक का कि जो कि आपको मैंने
अभी समझाया। आई होप कि आपको ये चीजें समझ
में आ गई होंगी। आई होप मतलब ये चीजें
क्लियर हो गई होंगी शायद। जो पूरा अटैक
चेन है आपका मैंने आपको क्लियर किया। अभी
यहां पे इसके थ्रू आपको ये पूरा का पूरा
चेन समझ में आ गया होगा। किस तरह से
क्या-क्या स्टेप्स होते हैं वह समझ में आ
गया होगा। हर स्टेप पे क्या होता है वह
समझ में आ गया होगा। जो टैकर का गोल होता
है एपीटी अटैकर का वह समझ में आ गया होगा।
कॉमन इंडिकेटर समझ में आ गए होंगे। डिफेंस
के टेक्निक्स समझ में आए होंगे और पूरा
एपीटी आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। आई होप सो
प्लीज लेट मी नो।
क्लियर है भाई? बताइए।
50k पर स्पेशल होगा। बिल्कुल। देखते हैं।
कुछ ना कुछ करेंगे स्पेशल। क्या स्पेशल
करें बताइए?
सर आप क्लास 10, 11, 12, 13 के नोट्स को
भेज दो। गौरव जांगरा। ठीक है गौरव अगर आप
एसओसी के फोर्थ नंबर ग्रुप में है तो
उसमें आ जाएगी। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है। चलिए
अब यहां पे आते हैं एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंट
थ्रेट के
एसओसी इंडिकेटर के उस पे।
ओके
एआई बोट इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हब यह बोलते हैं
हाय सर इट इट्स माय फर्स्ट लाइव क्लास आई
वाज्ड ऑलमोस्ट 50% ऑफ योर बग बंटी कोर्स
ग्रेट बहुत अच्छी बात है आपने 50% कर लिया
है 50% बाकी जो है उसको भी कर लीजिएगा इफ
आई गॉट यू बिफोर माय ग्रेजुएशन कंप्लीट
माय ऑल
टाइम हैज़ नॉट बीन हैज़ नॉट हैज़ बीन नॉट
वेस्टेड। अच्छा चलिए अभी भी टाइम वेस्ट
नहीं हुआ। आपने ग्रेजुएशन कर ली है। एक
डिग्री ले ली है। अच्छी बात है। दैट्स गुड
थिंग। अभी भी आपको अगर ये चैनल मिल चुका
है, डेफोनिक्स मिल चुकी है, तो अभी भी
आपके पास देयर आर अ लॉट ऑफ़ टाइम, इनफ टाइम
एंड यू कैन गो अहेड विद दैट। अभी भी आपके
पास सीखने के लिए बहुत कुछ बचा है। ठीक
है? लोग तो ग्रेजुएशन के बाद एक-एक साल का
गैप भी ले लेते हैं ताकि ज्यादा स्किल्स
गेन से कर सके अच्छे आगे फ्यूचर के लिए।
तो, अभी आपके पास टाइम है। बीइंग एन एसओसी
इंडिकेटर, एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंट थ्रेट के
लिए क्या हो सकती है? लो एंड स्लो
एक्टिविटी। बहुत स्लो एंड बहुत स्लो
एक्टिविटी। अनयूज़ुअल लॉग इन पैटर्न्स। लॉग
इन पैटर्न्स बहुत ही अनयूजुअल अगर आपको
डिटेक्ट हो रहे हैं। इंटरनल लैटरल मूवमेंट
आपको थोड़ा डिटेक्ट हो रहा है। जैसे मैंने
पहले बताया ही सस्िशियस पावर सेल यूज़ज़ ये
भी मैंने पहले बताया बीइंग एन एन एन एन एन
एन एन एन एन एन एसओसी। मैंने ये इमेज के
थ्रू भी बता दिया है। मैंने यहां पे जब
बताया था ना आपको कि कॉमन इंडिकेटर्स
एसओसी के लिए वो बता दिया है। फिर भी यहां
पे रिपीट कर देता हूं। डेटा को
एक्सिल्ट्रेट करना और अननोन डोमेनस जो कि
C2 के लिए होते हैं। अब रियल एसोसिएट
सिनेरियो की बात करें तो क्या होता है?
पहले यूजर ओपन्स फिशिंग ईमेल। फिशिंग
फिशिंग से स्टार्ट मान लो हम करते हैं
फिशिंग से। हालांकि इसके और भी स्टेप्स हो
सकते हैं। फिशिंग से स्टार्ट करते हैं।
फिशिंग ईमेल जो है यूजर ओपन करता है। पावर
शेल एग्जीक्यूट होती है। मान लो micad से
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग होती है। mmcड टूल से
एडमिन लॉग इन आ जाते हैं। एडमिन
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन हो जाता है। अब यहां
पे आरडीपी का यूज़ करके मल्टीपल सर्वर से
कनेक्ट किए जाते हैं। और डेटा ट्रांसफर जो
है एक्सटर्नल आईपी को किया जाता है। सारे
सिस्टम को कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने के बाद सारे
स्टेप्स होने के बाद जो स्टेप्स यहां पे
मैंने आपको बताए 12 स्टेप्स। ठीक है? सो
ये रैंडम नहीं है। ये एक एपीटीएच स्टाइल
अटैक चेन है जो यहां पे रियल एसोस
सिनेरियो में आपको बताया। राइट? आई होप कि
ये क्लियर हो गया हो। अब एपीटी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एंड नॉर्मल अटैक के बीच के डिफरेंस अगर
देखें हम एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंस फ्रेट और
नॉर्मल अटैक के बीच में तो ड्यूरेशन की
बात करें तो नॉर्मल अटैक बहुत छोटे या कम
ड्यूरेशन की होती है। एपीटी बहुत लॉन्ग
ड्यूरेशन की हो सकती है। गोल की अगर हम
बात करें तो यह तुरंत नॉर्मल अटैक के थ्रू
तुरंत आपका जो गोल है वो फुलफिल हो जाता
है। क्विक होता है और एपीटी में एक
स्ट्रेटेजिक एंड लॉन्ग टर्म में गोल आपका
गेन होता है। मतलब स्ट्रेटजी होता है कि
एक स्ट्रेटजी के थ्रू इतने टाइम में हमें
यह करना है। इतना टाइम हमें लगेगा। ये
स्ट्रेटजी के थ्रू होती है। डिटेक्शन की
बात करें तो बहुत ईज़ली आपका नॉर्मल अटैक्स
डिटेक्ट हो जाते हैं। एपीटी जैसे अटैक जो
है इनको डिटेक्ट करना बहुत हार्ड होता है।
ये बहुत ही स्ट्रेटेजिक होते हैं। बहुत ही
लॉन्ग टर्म होते हैं। बहुत लो प्रोफाइल
छोड़ने वाले अटैक होते हैं। तो डिटेक्शन
थोड़ी मुश्किल होती है। बिहेवियर की बात
करें तो काफी नॉइज़ होता है। एंड ये काफी
स्टिल होता है। बहुत ही छिपा हुआ होता है।
एंड हमारा नॉर्मल अटैक जो है बहुत ज्यादा
नॉइज़ करता है। बहुत ज्यादा दिक द शो ऑफ
करता है। अरे हम तो आ गए अटैक कर रहे हैं।
इस तरह की चीजें होती है। ये पूरा का पूरा
चीज होता है। अब देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] समझ में आ गया
होगा। एसओसी एनालिस्ट का माइंडसेट अगर हम
बात करें यहां पे व्हेन इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग
डोंट थिंक दिस दिस इज़ वन अलर्ट थिंक इज़
दिस पार्ट ऑफ़ अ बिग चेन अटैक। जब आप एसओसी
की तरह इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे हैं। एसओसी
एनालिस्ट हैं, एसओसी एल वन है तो आपको बस
यह नहीं सोचना है कि अच्छा यह तो यह एक
अलर्ट है। आपको ऐसा सोचना है कि यह जो
अलर्ट है, यह कोई बिगगर अटैक चेन का पार्ट
तो नहीं है। ऐसा सोचते हुए शुरू करना है,
स्टार्ट करना है। एंड यू विल ऑलवेज गेट द
करेक्ट स्पॉट।
ओके।
सर आप जब हम लोग रेन या कोई भी मलिशस
एक्टिविटी करते हैं तब हम लोगों को एसओसी
का लोग ब्लॉक क्यों नहीं करते जब रिकॉन
करते हैं या जब एक्सप्लइट करते हैं
नहीं रेकॉन के लिए ब्लॉक थोड़ी ना होता
है। रेकॉन के लिए ब्लॉकेज नहीं होती है।
हां, कई वेबसाइट्स होती हैं जो आप जब
बार-बार एक ही यूजर एजेंट या एक ही
ब्राउज़र से बार-बार आप रिक्वेस्ट भेजोगे
सेम आईपी से तो ब्लॉक हो जाती है। कई कई
ऐसी वेबसाइट्स हैं जो आपकी रिक्वेस्ट को
ब्लॉक कर देंगे। रिकॉर्ड प्रोसेस सही से
हो नहीं पाएगा। बट नॉर्मली ऐसा कुछ नहीं
होता। रिकॉन के लिए इतना हार्ड एंड फास्ट
रूल या ऐसी कोई सिक्योरिटी नहीं वो रखते
हैं कि हां भैया इतना ब्लॉक करना है कुछ
पकड़ना है। ऐसा
मैंने सर नेटवर्क वाली सीरीज 60% कंप्लीट
कर लिया है। बहुत शानदार है। मजा आया। वाह
बहुत अच्छी बात है।
सर अभी आईटी सपोर्ट में हूं और एसओसी
स्विच करना चाहता हूं। बस सिंपली आप इसको
फॉलो कर लीजिए। इस एसओसी सीरीज को। यू कैन
स्विच टू द एसओसी
सेक्टर। आप स्विच कर सकते हैं। दैट्स इट।
सो, बस यह था आज का सेशन। आज के सेशन के
लिए इतने ही टॉपिक्स थे आपके जिसमें हमने
डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग के बारे में पढ़ा,
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग के बारे में पढ़ा, एपीटी
एडवांस परेश थ्रेड के बारे में पढ़ा। और
इसी के साथ गाइज़ आप सभी का जो यह पार्ट
है, यह पूरा पोर्शन है, वह कंप्लीट होता
है। नाउ वी नेक्स्ट क्लासेस से आपके
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम स्टार्ट होंगे हमारे। एंड
हमारा यहां पे साइबर सिक्योरिटी मॉड्यूल
खत्म होता है। नेटवर्किंग का मॉड्यूल खत्म
होता है। एंड आर एव्री दीज़ काइंड ऑफ
मॉड्यूल्स जो इसके सपोर्टिंग मॉड्यूल्स थे
हमारे एसओसी के जितने भी सपोर्टिंग
मॉड्यूल्स थे वो सारे हमारे यहां पे आज
खत्म हो जाते हैं। अब हमारा मेन ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम मॉड्यूल जो कि एक और सपोर्टिंग
मॉड्यूल है हमारे एसओसी का लास्ट
सपोर्टिंग मॉड्यूल। एंड उसके बाद हमारा
एसओसी का एडवांस टॉपिक इंक्लूडिंग
प्रैक्टिकल लैब्स डेमोंस्ट्रेशंस एंड फिर
क्लोज़र एंड हमारी एंड की तरफ बढ़ेंगे हम इस
क्लासेस के इस कोर्स के एंड हमारा देन
कंप्लीट हमारी पूरी ट्रेनिंग कंप्लीट हो
जाएगी। फिर उसके बाद मैं आपको बताऊंगा कि
किस तरीके से सॉरी फिर मैं आपको बताऊंगा
कि किस तरीके से आपको इंटरव्यू के लिए
प्रिपेयर करना है। किस तरीके से अगर हम
कोई सर्टिफिकेशन आपके लिए लेकर आए तो उसको
किस तरीके से अप्रोच करना है। अगर कोई
टेस्ट लेते हैं तो वो कहां पे कैसे आपको
देना है, क्या करना है? ये सारा कुछ हम
फिर देखने वाले हैं। सो आई होप कि आपको आज
की क्लास में मजा आया होगा। आपको
इंटरेस्टिंग लगा होगा क्लासेस। जाते वक्त
एक बार लाइक ठोक के जाइएगा। बारी है टॉप
फैंस की लिस्ट पे आने की। सो एज़ यूजुअल
मैं आपको टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट दिखा देता
हूं। मैं पूरी फैंस की लिस्ट में पूरी पढ़
तो नहीं पाता हूं नाम क्योंकि बहुत ज्यादा
50 लगभग नेम्स होते हैं। बट स्टिल आई विल
शो यू दीज़ आर द टॉप फैंस लिस्ट पीपल जो
काफी एक्टिव रहते हैं। हमेशा आते हैं
हमेशा इंटरेक्ट करते हैं। ज्यादातर एक्टिव
रहते हैं। एंड
इनको भी धन्यवाद। बाकी जितने व्यूअर्स
जितने भी लर्नर्स यहां पे हैं उनको भी
धन्यवाद कि आप लोग कम से कम अपने आप को
अटेंशन दे पा रहे हैं। मैं धन्यवाद इसलिए
नहीं करता कि आप लोग व्यू यहां पे आके
व्यू दे रहे हैं। आप लोग क्लासेस अटेंड कर
रहे हैं। मैं धन्यवाद आपको इसलिए देना
चाहता हूं कि एटलीस्ट आपके अंदर अभी भी
उतनी सेंस है। आपके अंदर उतनी सोच है,
थिंकिंग है, थॉट्स हैं कि आप अपने लिए कुछ
स्किल गेन कर रहे हो। फ्री में जो मिल रही
है आपको ना एक पेड ट्रेनिंग लेवल की जो
स्किल्स मिल रही है पेड ट्रेनिंग की लेवल
की आपको एक ट्रेनिंग मिल रही है वो भी
एसओसी एल1 प्रोफाइल के लिए जो कि हर कंपनी
में चाहिए ही चाहिए फ्रेशर्स को ज्यादातर
हायर किया जाता है जिनकी सिक्स मंथ से वन
ईयर की भी एक्सपीरियंस है हायर किया जाता
है फ्रेशर्स को भी हायर किया जाता है या
जो सिर्फ इंटर्नशिप भी जिन्होंने करा है
कहीं से अच्छे से इंटर्नशिप भी करा है
उनको भी हायर किया जाता है वैसे रोल के
लिए आपको अगर एक सबसे शानदार ट्रेनिंग मिल
रही है एंड स्टिल यू आर एंजॉयंग द
ट्रेनिंग स्टिल यू आर जॉइनिंग द ट्रेनिंग
यू आर कमिंग फॉर द ट्रेनिंग देन दैट्स द
थिंग फॉर थैंकिंग यू दैट एक थैंकिंग करने
का यह एक बस रीज़न है मेरा आप सभी को। आई
होप कि आप सभी लास्ट लास्ट तक कंटिन्यू
रहेंगे। जो भी अभी यहां 50-60 लोग
कंटिन्यू रहते हैं वो एंड तक कंटिन्यू
रहेंगे। जो एंड तक कंटिन्यू रहेंगे आपके
लिए वो रिवॉर्डिंग होने वाली है। मेरा
यकीन कीजिए आप आपको काफी अच्छा रिजल्ट
मिलेगा लास्ट में। मुझे इतना पता है। ठीक
है? दैट्स इट। सो यहां पे आप सभी जो है अ
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सर आपके भरोसे हैं हम लोग बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
टेंशन नहीं लेना है आपको
सर बेस्ट स्टेट एंड कंट्री प्लेस फॉर जॉब
एंड इंटर्नशिप फॉर एसोसिए इंडिया
ओके चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां पे थैंक यू
वेरी मच गाइस एंड जाते वक्त एक लाइक ठोकते
चले जाइएगा सब्सक्राइब कर लीजिएगा चैनल को
अगर सब्सक्राइब आपने नहीं करा है स्टिल तो
सब्सक्राइब सब्सक्राइब कीजिए। सब्सक्राइब
करके बेल आइकॉन प्रेस कर दीजिए।
नोटिफिकेशन इनेबल कर दीजिए। और वीडियोस को
दोस्तों के बीच, कोलीग्स के बीच या जितने
भी एसोसिए एंथोजियास्ट हैं उनके बीच शेयर
जरूर किया कीजिए ताकि उन तक पहुंचे तो सही
यार और वीडियो जब भी आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखते
हैं तो लास्ट में वीडियो के नीचे में हाइप
का एक बटन होता है। उस हाइप के बटन पे
क्लिक कर दिया कीजिए। हाइप करने से
वीडियोस को रिकमेंड करती है YouTube। बस
यह एक हेल्प होगी ताकि YouTube इन वीडियोस
को मल्टीपल मैक्सिमम लोगों तक रिकमेंड
करें। जितने भी एसओसी एंथोजियास्ट्स हैं
उन सब तक ये वीडियोस पहुंचे एंड वो सब जो
है चाहे वो एथिकल हैकर्स भी हो पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर्स भी हो उनको अगर एसओसी की नॉलेज
होगी तो इट्स अ गुड थिंग इट्स एन एडेड
एडवांटेज एडेड स्किल तो उन तक पहुंचे एंड
उन लोगों की भी कुछ हेल्प हो उन लोगों को
भी ये नॉलेज या ये जो चीजें हैं नॉलेज
सीखने की वो उनको मिलता रहे। थैंक यू वेरी
मच गाइस। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में
बहुत जल्द जहां से हम स्टार्ट करेंगे एक
सेपरेट मॉड्यूल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स की। जब
उसको खत्म कर देंगे तो हमारा प्रैक्टिकल
एंड डेमोंस्ट्रेशन एसओसी का एडवांस टॉपिक
खत्म आएगा खत्म होगा एंड देन हमारी
क्लासेस खत्म होंगी। सो आई होप कि मजा
आएगा आपको। ठीक है? सो अभी के लिए थैंक यू
वेरी मच एंड शुभ रात्रि। गुड नाइट। टाटा
बाय-ब टेक केयर। मस्ती करिए, डिनर कीजिए।